party and let me know when they go live
with y'all see it and I'll let you know
if I see oh I see it on you too quick
laughs laughs laughs all right round two
and we are live again thank you oh yes
welcome to the iron Lords podcast and
the Lords of gaming dotnet episode
number 132 and it's another glorious
Sunday and we're back at the roundtable
not next to OBS on the Lord's Day a very
excited just yeah I just want everyone
to talk or court to make sure everybody
everybody sound it let's make sure that
you don't I'm about to get into it want
to give me your everybody counsel
numbers off Butch's Bush's batting how
we sound how we sell it can I continue I
can hear everybody underwater all right
no one's underwater we are bad yeah it's
fine all right
Lauria Sunday back at the roundtable
very excited about our special guest
we've got very special announcements
Xbox console streaming Blizzcon 2019
death stranding Xbox all-access and EA
going back to steam to discuss so we
gonna get right into it
I taught you God what did you do do
anything I would introduce the Lord who
ever my opinion is not only a great
friend to the room but is surely the
owner of some of the most balanced
perspectives in the entire gaming
community whether it be as passionate
takes on the games industry sensational
editorials or being an advocate for
mental health this Lord is definitely an
ambassador for the culture introducing
the creating host of the undead 3x VI
YouTube channel and gaming perspective
podcast still one of the best freelance
editors in the game Lord of baldur's
gate and the greatest pronunciation of a
boat you will ever hear gamings king of
the north
live from canada and making his return
into the realm of the lord mom
Lord undead 3xv how you doing sir you'll
have to be back here for ii feel like
that's deja vu i feel like i use in
canada it sound like a completely new
conversation yeah this is just really UD
what's good over there thank you for
surviving the difficulties I heard I
heard you see it every day when you're
going to work we didn't talk about 81st
ah thank you for granted that we see the
Statue of Liberty and we see other
buildings that's crazy
log table back in the realm have you
been man I'm glad to be here I got an
empty bucket beside me for all the knees
Lord undead in the building and of
course you know we got the original
Lords in a round table the four horsemen
of gaming my co-host with the cold most
my brother from another mother the
difficult game Conqueror Lord of reviews
and the howl of the young wolf my man
Lord addict are you doing sir
Stover here on you no strikes so
demanding my intro have to like go do a
strike strike next week after that oh
don't put no fat rats outside IO P Toby
China stop it oh don't stop it move its
destiny back on PC sir yeah I've been
playing a lot of destiny um I'm probably
gonna play some Luigi's Mansion here in
the next couple of days nice anything
else plant any you go out of worlds you
finished it right yeah I beat it
oh that's right I didn't eat it last
time I was here I beat it literally an
hour or two after the podcast oh we
already got a super shine
take care this is a he changes his name
a [ __ ] you know you can't be trying to
host a podcast using a trial Wow Wow why
I got a good what you might be onto
something
well I got a head al well trial with the
33:6 motor bed with the crackling sound
damn yo yo shout to the chat everybody
sticking with us man is to appreciate
OBS man in the bushes in the bushes
trust me on god I meant you're worth
your while you know what I blame for our
unfortunate events would you blame kits
move for no reason oh and of course we
have our most technical gaming Lord the
solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also the
sastra Thomas
mr. Omar profile Illuminati and draw a
picture of the iron bank mom made North
sovereign how you doing sir what's going
on everything is beautiful mm-hmm I have
to tell you man like Moz you know you
know when a fighter you think he's sort
of plateaued and then he figures
something out yeah good analogy great
enough and and that's what Marvel doll
has done he's figured something out and
on top of that he's admittedly he he's
never trained as hard as he has now like
he realized look I'm not giving it the
effort that I need to give it yes I need
to change up how I do things
and the results are evident too dude
obviously I mean fighting in backyards
with Kimbo Slice is the way this dude is
a know that it's a king form you know
that's a funny thing I've seen those
videos a million I don't know that was
you know
Oh Horace all glad I said we tried to
get a hold on one second the super shot
out to 108 dragons TV with the $5 super
chat set up to the realm and keep up the
great content and you sir supreme you
keep calling for my knees I'll let you
borrow my knees that'll give you like a
good 6 more inches of height perfectly
followed by I busy with the $2.00 let us
not forget the DS King Oh sob so I will
let supreme borrow them first
so King how you feel that does he comes
at you every week over these knees I
love it the level of dedication this man
I can't I can't tell you I really
honestly feel super flattered at this
point now he actually has invested into
this situation you know what we're gonna
do we're gonna take all the money we're
gonna give it back to you so when you
put your PlayStation this inside you can
actually play back the back you gonna
put that plate you gonna put that
destiny 2 in that PS 5 okay you can
definitely play this for $9.99 from your
local bank will we take MasterCard
they're not taking that they want
Bitcoin untraceable currency man like he
the B C's turn that corner and he's
figured out what it takes for him to win
and be successful and lose boxing like
when you when you win they're against
you and they're against maybe as the
boxer has to be on point and if there's
anybody who has boxing comparable to him
is my pad all no doubt all wild gratis
whoa boy stitch 66 69 with the two lot
of super check good day Lords kanabi was
up to subdue he ready ready for that
time
so yo when did you watch any of the
Velox of what he was doing like training
going up because this I think this is
the Maz Biddulph being what I wanted it
to be because let's not forget man when
he did the Ashman right listen that's
that's not is I think he's gonna
recommend for probably the shortest
fight in UFC history it is they're
calling in five seconds but it's
actually about three seconds
yeah it's about three seconds because he
didn't have to do anything else um but I
watched the vlogs right and I was
looking at everything and it had
multiple different streams like one was
talking about the history in the past
the other one was talking about his
training and the other one was talking
about the psyche of a fighter going
forward right so I felt that in UFC was
letting this rock really hard one of
them was promoted by UFC was promoted by
him and another was promoted by an
independent and I thought because I
called for it before that they needed to
push this guy to the forefront and start
showing him in his light let let's start
celebrating the hard work of this Cuban
that came over you know his all the
horrible colleagues back
you know he came with the Scarface music
y'all know it was fire it was beautiful
I felt I really wished I would have got
a chance to watch this with you yeah you
know with you guys this to you know to
get that old-school feel back yeah it
was a bully versus a bully yes and the
bullies respecting it was no shenanigans
going up to the fight you know even
after obviously we know is you know I
don't say early establish but at the end
of day yay dick was bloodied but it was
just one of those things that it's like
damn we just wish it want to continue
even though Martha doll was piecing them
let's just keep it true you see the
thing is Nick you never know he gets a
curse the for heart mm-hmm be patient
sir I just want you to buckle in I'm not
you know whatever chair you sitting in
right now hope you got a seat belt
I got all I was gonna say is that like I
agree with yourself like you just wish
cuz even though my Fidel was doing
everything he's clearly won the fight at
the point of no stoppage but you just
wish it goes on because we know Nick
gets stronger as it goes on and if we
want to see if mastered I would have
passed that test but the cool thing that
it was like he was like oh we could run
it back and I'm saying both of them was
willing to run him back so right but
yeah it was great great fight that's
what I thought anything else you've been
doing watching clean what's going on
yeah of course the boxing but I'll leave
that to King we can't but uh I haven't I
played a little bit of outer worlds this
morning I really want to get into that
but I'm you know working crazy I did
play some Luigi's Mansion away from home
I did yo I haven't honestly I didn't
play dark moon
I didn't play really a lot of the
original Luigi's Mansion when it came
out for gamecube so this is my first one
there's a really pretty game man I guess
it's a very nice little release before
the big guns come mom but I'm enjoying
it so far
know thou shalt to Victor Alice ding the
to our super chat what's good Lords fine
Sunday here's sloop Victor Alice Dean
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka
the XS gamer ooh the lord of combat
sports king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
fraud alert movement Oh beloved Lord
King how you doing sir did you know you
better not do the dead striding stuff
we're saving that for you to a check
that'll be you ain't keeping nothing to
check the day chief Tommy is going on
you see the death of his own app right
there I had to bend the knee so Eddy
Hearn and his design which we read let
me tell you something like ok so they
got that this is what the app does did
the app is about fighting MMA and it has
a whole broad spectrum of sports right
so there's a sport that was like this
more than ESPN
and it's $100 for the year $20.00 a
month I paid for the year you know you
know 12 months you know $10 less than
$10 a month is worth it you get over I
think it's like a hundred fights a month
mm-hmm oh that right yes it's definitely
worth the bang for the buck and it was
good fights coming up and this was the
way I was going to get a chance to see
Canelo vs. Kovalev now Henry Armstrong
is the only person that was holding
three belts at the same time that was in
three different weight divisions right
so he conquered three different
champions at the same time holding those
belts without relinquishing any belts oh
okay
the only person that has done that since
Henry Armstrong is Canelo Alvarez now as
of this moment so if you got a chance to
watch this fight you sure you saw the
cash cow the money cash cow that's in
boxing right now don't forget that one
el that he has on his record
Floyd Mayweather gave him that l and he
made it look like it was walking apart
yeah facts all right now this is not to
discredit Canelo that's to just show you
how great flight is Canelo is a
transcendent fighter mm-hmm all right
he's in otherworldly everybody thought
he was scared of triple G he fought
triple G twice he said I really don't
mean for me to show the guy he has
nothing to offer me I'm going to bigger
and better things I'm looking for
greater challenge even though it's not
in color tozzoli tree is coming at you
he said get as Canelo soft Blanc
oh no I'm gonna see if he real if he
stay at light weight he he not buy in
the Canal Zone and listen I got you let
me let me explain a couple of things as
a boxer you map out your strategy to get
to your goals right now this guy is
chasing legacy he's not chasing the
dollars he he already gets the money
mm right he's chasing to have his name
stamped on a level now there's other
Mexicans that came out that did not
appreciate him fighting old fighters
right and did not appreciate them
fighting shot fighters it's not his
fault that that man was champion and he
decided to take the fight and when you
decide to take the fight from the cash
cow of course Kovalev got 13 million
dollars to get his head smoked yesterday
other dudes that could have took 13
million if they had smoke and I'm pretty
sure Canelo will definitely bring that
smoke one thing we won't do is say that
this man has never come up every time he
comes into that ring he comes in shape
he comes ready to fight and he leaves
his heart out on that floor now how he
gets there is two different things
if he chooses to don't fight
well he didn't fight cuz he fought Danny
Jacobs y'all thought he wasn't gonna
fight Danny Jacobs he fought triple G
y'all thought he wasn't gonna fight your
bujji he went up and fought every
champion there just because he didn't
fight a the charlo brothers no no
there's no money there he's going to
where there's less risk high reward
instead of high risk no reward because
you beat charlo not too many people know
charlo but a lot of dudes know Kovalev
facts
alright so we're not gonna get down on a
fighter that just made history last
night right ok so no fightin corporal
ever is keeping them off the whole fight
and I thought honestly I thought Kovalev
was winning the fight I'm not even gonna
be s you know I said to myself I said
off and then he hit him on the top of
the head and that needed that thing he
wasn't right and then I saw Canelo eyes
keep eyes lit up like candy naw when
kids see candy Christmas what are we
because he learned from Floyd fight and
he grew in boxing yes
so again so he hit him with a right hand
to the top of the head set it back up
with a jab then came over with that
right that crushed his soul and entered
him with that left hook against the
but the body shots mmm that he was
giving this dude when he kissed the
ropes when his lips was against the
world
okay and he thought the FINA champion my
heart sank
yeah because you're not coming back from
that mm-hmm I joined I was like bro why
is this man make him out it's like he
wanted a private moment with the rope
and he just looked to the side it was
just it was just funny us I never see
the man slope like that and just stay in
that position it's very intimate Brazil
the Rope in his neck dope all right
listen guys you know a lot of times we
have um we have a half man talk that's
that man talk let me take off this hat
real quick get ready you're ready cuz
you know a lot of times people don't
understand man talk I saw this week I
had to put out a tweet I saw this week
Dean's is coming at the throne not
indirectly right it's not dude it's one
dude and you know this switching side is
a habitual line step of do and listen
when you a turncoat we don't we don't
look at you the same Benedict Arnold and
y'all should get that you understand you
should understand when when you Benedict
honor when you slip over there you go
over and you talk and stuff just for the
likes and the views and the comments but
then you see something that's real are
you trying to attach a name to something
that's real let's not hurt your feelings
oh let me give you something
Christopher Hart split up for somebody
that he shouldn't just stood up for
mm-hmm
cuz I prepped Christopher Hart more than
the so-called bozos what the play should
be all right my place they should put
the crown on my head we wrap in what
they owe a date with Danny you don't got
what what they talk about you see that
this is a Playstation
and controller from date and date of
purchase no look it's the old one when I
went to the store not when I purchased
three PlayStation systems and I got
three extra controllers mm-hmm yeah all
right then when we're done when they
went up to the pro and when it got three
pros oh this is one this is one of my
Vitas it's one of my feet is one of them
told you about taking my Vitas I guess
we don't one is moderate with them when
it was doing this let me tell you
something more than you so-called bozos
that's out here running around talking
all that mess and you you listen y'all
want to start a channel I'm talking
about you switch sides you're gonna
throw your xbox in the bushes financial
reasons is why you did that likes is why
you did that you can't support two
ecosystems that's why you did that man
talk telling people the truth
don't nobody know bs so so we've got
it's not it's not what they try to do
they try to separate have us as
separatist oh listen what happened when
it was video games was supposed to be
our last bastion that that had us
together you know let's be in school I'm
gonna give you a story real quick a
small story to a man talk the still man
talk all right so is this kid that's in
the yard he always keeps his self in
here a game boy when the game boy first
came out he's sitting there playing his
game boy and some of my friends decided
it was a good thing to start bullying
this kid because he was playing the game
boy said he went over there and I had a
Nintendo in my house I'm on my heart yo
yo yo what you doing can't do that baby
what you doing you ain't gon
oh boy hmm and mean him had such the
great friendship from there because we
started talking about the game and when
we played he come over to my house I
went over to his house and then we found
more of us it was ridiculed and we was
laughed at and we're not being laughed
at now guys that we the cool kids now I
know you doing man talk but you okay go
it's just two things in denim and let
you get at it because it is these dudes
don't understand some way along the line
is a separatist agenda mmm they trying
to make you feel like you have to choose
there's no choice don't eat races games
do financially can't handle one thing is
cool your man's supposed to pick you up
in that area and be able to go to your
man's house and play that PlayStation if
you can't afford to ecosystems you're
supposed to be in a community that
allows you to flourish you know somebody
because financially they can't handle
something so we got super chance right
go ahead before King goes back artists
right we got the $2 from a shroom
Kingdom while the PSP go to the original
sad edition you got that game yeah yeah
he's got that okay so we got a $2.00
super chef from one-eighth dragon Saint
Christina or defrauding easy I'm just
reading man so I got the $5 super - I'm
not gonna try to butcher your name but
I'll try mm-hmm has it here I don't have
a great show Lord's key stuck the key
sets up pocket right all right so listen
we have to start bring this is this is
why we're different we're not gonna talk
that whole everybody here has everything
all right we're not gonna sit here maybe
I'm a joke around on some PlayStation
I'm a joke around on some Nintendo I'm
not trying to have beef over video games
that you are my brother
facts my sister we are together here
facts that's our living I'll just finish
up on the joker's yeah like can you just
like that's why all this thing you use a
term that I always laugh you call a
weirdo energy and it's like dang it it's
a lot of weirdo energy and at the end of
the day the reason why don't even
involve with it is because I don't care
what side you on you pick up a
controller you my bro automatic off rip
so at the end of the day that's what
unifies us all this separatist joint it
is a lot of pocket watching and there's
a little OTT of people who maybe they
can't afford or whatever their situation
is both things that's fine you made a
decision but there's no need for us to
be separate when we all gamers and we
all love the same damn thing like that's
ridiculous so yes Seleucus a little old
man and super chest Bolin shout out the
Philly Eagle King David just turn both
Keys drop some nukes yo shout-out to
pixel [ __ ] G vibro King talking my
language gamers loves games full stop
we played them all across platforms
diehards are masking their wallets with
fandom yeah you know the funny thing is
you know we might junk around but
literally we all play every game almost
almost every game that comes out you
know Kiki might clown a little bit more
than I do on the switch but you know we
still play these games listen you just
said Luigi Lynch and I was like oh my
god is a helper out for my five cents
please please much and people on social
media I am a single income family with
two kids
I got PlayStation I got Xbox the idea
that if you buy a specific video game
console you go to the store you go to
your Walmart your Costco and you spent
$400 on a console and that makes you
special
mmm it does not and people sit there and
talk crap bad it's like I can go Walmart
buy a ps4
$14.99 I can go Walmart get an Xbox for
$2.99
mmm did not make you any better than
anyone else reach it right trade [ __ ]
brother you're on a level playing field
if you want to spend $7,000 on a PC be
my guest guys buy an xbox one by 10 Xbox
one don't play $7000 to build a
fantastic PC plays out the Lord lemon
get chilled with the file a super chat
gets you wait up I work harder don't be
a window shopper we gave miss and I gave
on every hashtag you already know pocket
watch of y'all you know you know that
sounds like something King would say
don't be a window shop wanna wait no to
fobs shop all day long
we got another segment later on it's
gonna go into affordable stuff and stuff
that's happening guys I it breaks my
heart when I sit there and I watch the
narrative being switched and you guys go
at each other so hard in these chats and
and yeah I'm not really there's no
reason because you're just masking your
insecurities anytime you can do
something of that nature to another
individual that you have a common bond
with then when y'all get off of that
phone and stop tweeting you go go in
your living room and your bedroom you're
getting the same thing that's what came
with the ceremony let me get going we
got logs show isn't it but it cakes a
loop bro that out you killed it man how
you cut it on our of course you already
know me Laura Cognito the cooperative
experienced the gaming ninja same old
stuff man I mean for me it's just being
on outer worlds got to play a little bit
more get a little bit farther
obviously ex-client I will discuss on my
segment about how the console streaming
is going shadow keeping doing that
goodness and that's it but we got a lot
of show y'all so let's get into it
Lord solved we got some announcements
man yeah man we got something we got
some bills to pay absolutely no first
first Sunday the month so obviously
we're doing that patreon and of course
we have some winners to announce and our
gleam giveaway so we don't know what the
patreon first because you know gotta
gotta show love to our to our patrons
absolutely every single week month III
reiterate this thank you guys for all
the support you give us every single
month to get new patrons coming in is
fantastic the love and the support you
got show us so thank you really
appreciate let's get into these
shoutouts start off first was our boy
the Lord is finally joining the loyal
when it comes to round table reviews
Lord Amen salut je vais that's a joke a
brother
they're so low co2 jailer he put me on
where a little chicken sandwiches at for
Papa those things are like the dodo man
you can PEO he put me on the spot near
me Oh bro pull up pull up below to the
arm to the what's that what's that place
you like to go to South Oh
plataforma some of those LeBron ice out
here start out you are forever patron
Lord Cora lytic aka Lord rocky bro sleep
in peace cane and of course Lord
followed by low slow-mo back slap thank
you for the support my brother salute
next up we have Lord HB 33 thank you sir
for support salute the cat daddy fast a
mm don't eat that fake file it's call me
bro I gotta try it man I need to crack
in my life continue I don't think I want
that we have Lord Nintendo Direct thank
you sir and of course next up we have
UFC Fan Oh 321 aka rate the emperor
brave to hem fro always children next up
we have Lord QX 7 masters thank you my
brother q x7 salut
and then of course Lord Zorro looks
alright thank you for the support it's a
little brother thank you next up we have
Lord fastback 67 69 out of the MLG and
Dallas Cowboy himself keep killing that
fantasy league of man he beat everybody
I love - elite continue and of course
our brother in the chat Lord stitch 66
69
it's his favorite system as a switch
[Laughter]
kundo thank you homie homie - mm-hmm
next up we have one of the most positive
brothers in all of these YouTube streets
we have our friend Lord gaming Forte Oh
select would say he'd be giving a lot of
inspirational stuff oh yeah racial stuff
showing a lot of love I was feeling that
the Halloween he was used in salute to
my bro that's what's up
and of course our esteemed guest today
Lord undead 3xb I just have to enquire
it was the bag dropped off sir do we
have the Lord of X cloud Lord bill still
well know his greatness oh thanks and of
course one of our brothers from across
the pond Lord Sammy Prescott thank you
so sad did Sammy next up we have Lord
Night Music thing I know he was
he was number one in the chat updated
you falling off man you're not you're
not first and I'm chatting friend and
brother till around the Lord of the
chanclas
absolute the Brava dave was supported
salute PC master race pc master race
himself of course our very first patron
Lord monkey punch himself Michael Lugo
they shot down find his brother trouble
that brother yeah no dad next up we have
the Lord of the stream team and the king
of the ban hammers himself Lords now
though I do so once again I have to
shout out for the hard work he does yes
you know banning these fraudulent
accounts it was like 10,000 they're
trying to get their game they're trying
to get them games many want that could
really try this little piddy no doubt
and up necks of course family from the
cradle to the grave aka Lord loaded
pixels and bird and not hurt yes thank
you I have to ask you that even saying
just call them Colbert so we know oh
shout out the Lich people charity with
the fire I don't know what the but a
good Morgan good morning from germany
good Lords happy Sunday to y'all gamers
unite your Rudy no SMI doer I did Luton
ah guten how you say good Morgan I like
it's a good more guy best morning I
guess that's me Google Morrissey we
don't see you at Gamescom one year
brother yes what about that plan for you
we would definitely link up and you got
to show me with a good up there is that
cuz I heard they got the real bear we
got well cigar so next up we have Lord
Tao so cheap
knowing a fighting guy he was honest he
was only Twitter talk about shout-out to
Bradley mm yeah I heard pcmasterrace
next up we have Lord cat daddy fat stack
best luck to cold
thank you take speed a man with all the
color shirts and of course the next up
we have Lord Jaime period oh yes we did
all round table reviews the one um yes
but yeah shout out to him or now I'm a
now else oh we did spy to me and a home
come I mean coming saluted my bro you
know say I'm waiting for the viewership
to get a little bit livelier yes I got
it I got something to drop on you guys
captain promptly say something with the
20 whatever currency from your country I
believe it was Norway or Norwegian krone
know widget yeah do it yo shout ah but
please leave a comment so we can get
some words in front man we want to shout
you our brother thank you so much man
really really appreciate it and of
course last but never least a friend
from across the pond a brother from
across the pond Lord debt sting absolute
from Baltar Baltar is that you we play
destiny you was in the armed PC discord
let me know if that's you because I
remember that bowl talking in salute
brother from Norway you already know and
that is it for our patrons thank you
once again for the monthly support guys
we really appreciate it as I've said
before none of this is possible without
you guys so thank you for everything and
of course like you guys anything you
guys want to see us do add or whatever
just leave it whatever just getting us
on Twitter get it us on the patreon and
we're definitely working to improve and
evolve everything that we do so
definitely
and we definitely gonna hit these shows
and we're setting it up some community
events we're gonna start doing but we're
still in the problem the beginning
stages of doing that yeah we working on
that so obviously we had a lot of
announcements on that soft thank you for
that going ahead I'm too excited
together so let's get into these
giveaway right this ten dollar giveaway
of the ten dollar gift card giveaway a
Lord linchpin anytime we have anything
overseas probably will figure it he paid
it forward real quick he's a father of
me make you ten drop the bag yeah see
it's rigged come on stitch alright and
now the winner of the $20 super chat
Lord CD FS look to within a minute
before he was winning every weekend it
was definitely all right now let's get
into this teespring giveaway whoa what
the trip
who was that this is a good segue all
right and the winner of our teespring
giveaway for the month of November a
hit solve account quick snitch teespring
Joey saw we good on about to get into
this gleam real quick unless you want to
do that okay
all right hold on get that super chair
real quick while he dropped it back in
oh my god
oh my bad guy um we got lynchpin I gotta
drop the bag got to get some back to
briar bag all about balance hood
linchpin balance all right I'm gonna
have to have you focus on what's being
done right now the bold new line in the
room of the lords repeat Dominus Maximus
s tea brought to you what's alive by the
new lord of the realm graphic God be
brave and always be a lord let me tell
you something graphic God has went to
great lengths and he put out a great
logo and I would like to welcome him
into the realm as far as our artists go
our other great artist Sharla Bray
mm-hmm the narrow Panero for never oh we
have other great artists that works on
the other visual size so it's it's
finally a thing going on right now
that's up in a teespring store right now
I look it Kofi
Dominus Maximus link is in description
it's in the description also real quick
so okay
don't forget y'all yeah I'm not limited
yeah I got other colors you get that
green you know I'm saying
look at that red you're not limited to
the default color there so scroll at the
bottom you know I'm saying we got the
joint for the ladies too whatever you
want to do and I'm saying I'm going make
sure y'all get that fill Dominus
Maximus is it sooner Ilya sooner really
really show up later by understanding we
originators we are the creators are we
also be up for you guys and going in
support when you hear that feel Dom yeah
I know it came from the Lords so they
don't got the IUP on the back rear
salute the graphic God he did a
phenomenal job on this and again all the
talented artists in the realm dinero
Panero short lady like you said and I
believe off all graphic God also did all
the last word for me any bounces to
maybe I've got a beast please support
the room we know we are the originators
of the saying we do this so support that
Dominus
Maximus fail you know I'm saying still
I'll actually said Cox I like a ball
Basildon I've out here fella desert I'm
walking girl all bull talk I owe you
change his name to bolts a little
brother much appreciated man so you
already know and all we got some more
special announcement I know as you guys
know into to gleam giveaways and one
stranding and one for Pokemon either
sword or shield and the Pope are one
still has a little ways to go but of
course with the stranding coming out on
the 8th it is now time to announce our
gleam giveaway winner for that's
stranding for the ps4 once again big
shout out to uh to Lourdes PD Lourdes
now though for all the hard work he does
and and bringing out the banhammer and
getting rid of these frauds that said
the winner of our gleam giveaway for
death stranding is Lord Fritos bondo
those bundles okay Rondo's absolutely no
vetoes I will get at you on Twitter let
you know that you have won this and I'll
get you that code hopefully I don't know
if it's up for free download whatever
but I'll try to get through the code as
quickly as possible so you ready to go
on Friday that's right you can walk to
the store to go pick it up are you gonna
be walking in making toast you already
know so um look we got one more I know
it's been a lot of no and no show keep
everybody awake but up yet look it's
just been a tremendous show we want to
give back to love thank you guys for
being there you know I want to set it
off because um as you know you know the
Lord's with this whole iron law
podcasting and of course Lords of gaming
down there grass roots from the ground
up by the gamers you know what I'm
saying and um we've just been extremely
blessed to cross paths with you guys a
lot of people fantastic talents in the
gaming industry and stuff like that with
a lot of knowledge but more importantly
a lot of people that are good people so
with all that being said I'm extremely
proud to announce our latest acquisition
to the Lords of gaming dotnet family our
very own lord of the realm Undead
three XVI in the building he brings a
wealth of industry editing experience
super passionate heartfelt writing just
journalistic integrity what car did some
Rainbow six siege man Lord undead
glad to have you in the room the floor
is yours brother
hey glad to be here glad to be part of
the team people don't know me I've been
writing and doing everything for about
four years I've been doing a lot of
small stuff and doing some big stuff
I've had some big pieces I've had some
not big pieces I've done a lot of
different things I'm really excited to
see what I can do with you
is going forward and let me just say
that 2019 may just be closing but 2020
is gonna be a whole different story
whoa yo much appreciated man and salute
on dead man me like I said this is a
very talented brother a lot of deals on
the table you don't say
rightfully because he's a tremendous
talent and just the fact that he chose
to build the Lord's truly humbling you
know it's gonna be an honor to work
alongside you bro and I'm saying and we
definitely want to take long to the next
level we have a great team you know I'm
saying some great editors on poor we got
Lord dizzy we got North Josh reading the
team you know saying is so many of us
that I've joined in it's just grass
roots so we're super pumped they have
been around and all we want to do some
specials let's dig let's make history
brother so glad to have you in glad
thank you thank you again for for
choosing the Lord sort around Lord's a
game it was logo wasn't a baby I gotta
find and I said he's like man we gotta
we gotta figure out a way to make
karl-anthony towns and envy it in a ring
at the best part about that is I was out
somewhere I was like Walmart or
something with my kids these messages
[Laughter]
[Music]
shout out to everybody there hit them up
enough pocket baby thank you thank you
20 min look out for us look out for
Lords in the image that net possibly
about through the roof yeah it's about
to be self special happening ma'am so
salute salute let's get on with some
damn show we don't even got the
contractual stuff out the way all
announcement are done um everything out
the way Lord on dead last time you're
here suppose the world chicken leaves
I'll be seventy one outstanding video
game history we're not gonna get into
that cuz it's been documented but I do
need to ask you because your top five at
the time I need to know if it remains
the same at the time you had number five
hit man number four Metal Gear Solid
number three Splinter Cell number two
halo and number one God of War as your
top five video game franchises of all
time
has anything changed should I get to
alter this list sir well I can't say
after spending babe oh wow I'm a legend
yo I don't even know it's not out okay
you go ahead that's a different color
well not Steve red in the chat and you
put up five that's 500 chrome that's 500
chrome I don't even know what that
equates to but I know I've never seen
that color blood in my own when you go
into iron man blood-red
segments sir love this podcast cut bro
you guys make us in salute that norway's
salute the bull talk wow I don't even
know the same I don't even know to say I
am truly truly enroute like with this
support we get we brought not the
biggest but I think we have one of the
most loyal bases I think that on you
guys really give us energy Thank You Man
I don't even know what to say bro dad
that's that's crazy
shout out to UM dizzy with the file a
super chat welcome aboard undead
everyone be sure to go and put more
Lords of gaming website salat writing
and we don't bend the knee to any devil
publisher louver thank you so much bro
thank you so much let us continue undead
I'm sorry we was told much a5 real quick
with anything change
kijima slander that's so trust me that's
not always good salute
so anything so some top takes the spot
or a figure ball this was it man
I spent my picked up that game my wife
ordered it without telling me because I
had canceled my pre-order because things
were tight I'd get some stuff for my
kids done and I come home from work 15
hour day I was like I just want to curl
up in a bend I my wife
there's something on the Xbox for you
whoo so I go over and sitting is a
physical copy of Baldur eight one and
two and I went knowing me so much and
understanding how much gaming needs to
me when she doesn't even
shann about the game in life at all
that's what's up but she completely
understands how much it means to me and
how much that game meant to me so that's
what that games go on listener oh it's a
little good to have all this game a
salute to lady undead representing the
realm in the right way let's get it to
the poll last week poll results are
ending the people have spoken with the
recent release and positive reviews
received by obsidian and outer worlds in
game Pass does this give you more
confidence in the quality of game paths
as a service moving forward the winner
of the three-way il people in a land
slide 91% by the highest ever is yes
game path still provides great value and
proof that phil was on to something for
next men group coming in at second place
at only 7% no game pass is mostly fodder
in quality and at last place at a close
four percent to the seven percent was I
don't care don't shame me for paying the
$60 for a game Sheila shoot up to all
the lords that were in around last
week's that participated Lord solve I
heard you chirping sir oh no it's
exactly right I mean I you remember when
when it's fated kay
to came out it was we didn't feel that
way but a lot people for like okay they
said this is their way to give us games
that aren't ready and not done f-for a
cheap price and you know that was some
of the narrative around we didn't feel
that way but I you know but once you
start seeing games like out of worse
gears v you know everything coming out
of first party they're gonna try their
hardest for that to be a super polished
product so I mean is there's only better
things coming for game pass now like if
you think about next-gen all of these
games coming out of these city studios
you know you're gonna get some pretty
polished products in addition to
whatever third party deals they're able
to make because again they even getting
better that I mean when you talk about
Metro coming on there a month or two
after it after it came out after
launched like this is the stuff we're
gonna see more and more up so implants
always been great it's only getting
better no doubt you already know so
that's what we got we gonna get into
these topics to set it off with Nord
addict first let's because actually just
a breaking news this is more recent than
the topics we had initially discuss
Blizzcon went down man is certain games
you excited about what's going on man so
Blizzcon went down and uh the biggest
thing that they announced from there is
a Diablo for an overwatch to what I
think's funny is they finally announced
Diablo 4 and I'm just thinking myself if
that's cuz they didn't really show hole
up then I'm like why don't you just show
that like six months ago when your whole
fanbase is gonna like Lynch you like
they were going at you hard cord you
finally show something in its that
mmm-hmm that you know they showed a lot
of gay player in the first level
they showed something to call it the war
oh boss or everyone in that facility
could find a boss they showed a really
cool cinematic trailer overwatch they
showed some you know some gameplay in a
cinematic trailer but what I want to ask
someone is uh is is the industry still
on that we ain't buying nothing because
it's like you know it's like me and
Morcar need always say like it's to
gamers it's not about what you've done
it's what you doing for me right now
I find it funny how from one day it goes
from I'm boycotting everything Blizzard
does to the next things I'll kill that
Diablo for looks right now and I think
gamers are guilty of this all the time
we're real quick to get up on a soapbox
and [ __ ] and moan about certain things
talk about all this big talk for when
the rubber hits the road and you it's
time to either pull out the wallet or
not nine times out of ten the wallet
comes out mm-hmm because at the end of
the day and me and I don't necessarily
for people with this I'm here for the
games I'm not here for the politics I'm
not here for the drama I'm here innings
and often times you cannot fault an
entire company of hard-working people
most of most of which don't necessarily
have to be in line with what their
company you know what that company
mantra is what the company line is
they're there to do their job make games
that people love so I don't feel after
that it's it's a tough thing for me to
to boycott something that I know is
gonna hurt a lot of people that work
very hard on something I do feel like
there are certain circumstances where
there has to be collateral damage so I
like the Star Wars Battlefront 2 thing
you know I think there are certain
circumstances where something drastic
has to happen like the Xbox one at 2013
you know the entire internet was like we
ain't having you and that's one of the
reasons the Xbox is where it's at now
like no.17 buying it I wouldn't care
what it came out of came a DRM coulda
came with a whole security guard on top
of it what's the security guard garden
like your Xbox gonna make okay he was a
spy take your phone is fine sir listen
I'm playing this game I don't care what
happened I could tell me a whole bunch
of stuff and while if it's my favorite
game if it has something that I care
about I don't care I'm buying it and you
could look at me any way you want I'm
going right through that line
I'm gonna go right inside and walk right
through that line you physically put a
finger on me a situation gonna turn
deadly but are you crossing picket lines
King doesn't cross picket lines he owns
the company that's been hundreds 73 in
the chat yeah please hit that like
button
really appreciate it bunch of preciate
let's get Laura dead on this man I mean
Blizzcon went down obviously is a major
announcements but what did you think
about the announcements and obviously
the controversy that's been going on as
well in conjunction with it Lord a day
look I can count
I've need a calculator to calculate the
amount of times that people on social
media get mad at a game company but I
can count on one hand how many times
people are stuck with that all say in
this very few circumstance it's
overwatch yeah they're not doing
anything right now so of course I'm
gonna boycott you know what I love
undead I love what people say they're
gonna boycott a game they have no
intentions on buying that's like the
equivalent of man coming out you know I
don't like what he eggs do and I'm
boycotting it hey it wasn't buying it
anyway I respect people like Jeff Gordon
who came out and canceled his World of
Warcraft subscription after having
10,000 plus hours in the damn game that
means something I can't do my - and even
after all those announcements he's still
saying they're going I'm still not going
to support them oh I can't remind to for
financial reasons though my pockets
before this stuff popped up which I
don't know about whatever popped up I
had
before Dan and I had put a lot of hours
into but when I started using too much
money I was spending like $100 a week on
this game buying gold I have to leave
sorry honestly in the end of the day
people like to be on the moral high
ground about this stuff we don't but the
end of the day you're wearing Nikes
they're built in sweatshops in Asia and
wearing you're wearing your name brand
clothes they're made by slave labor in
China we support this game and then go
out and kick a cat I don't like I didn't
like Borderlands 3 I don't like Randy
Pitchford I don't like gearbox I need my
that game when everyone's like boycott
Borderlands 2 guys like oh yeah see them
MPD numbers are being in reference to
from the blizzards they're for it do you
think this was like strategically set up
they knew everything was at a fever
pitch they had you know people
boycotting outside this thing right like
literally outside of Blizzcon like do
you think like they like look we got a
hit up with these heavy hitters a data
kind of shut up the nonsense like do you
think this is strategically planted
these two
I mean Diablo Floyd and oh wow these are
like blobs so you think it was it was
strategic I I think they realized that
they put their foot in it this time my
bliss has been putting their foot in it
[Laughter]
like they really put their foot in it
but at the same time they also know that
if they drop Diablo for that
[Laughter]
the president come out and actually give
some some kind of Maricopa like yeah
sorry you guys felt the way you did but
it is what it did but did he even
apologized for the issues that people
had had like that's that I heard a lot
of the complaints were that he really
didn't address or reduce I guess you
know the whole stream or the hearthstone
thing with the Hong Kong thing so yeah
that's because the president doesn't
care yeah he's not and he's not gonna
he's not a gamer mm that's when you're
not a gamer that's mean you're so
disassociated from what your product is
that you can't identify with your base
and you think you know some of their
kings he's not a gamer you know I have
to say that because if you don't eat
chicken and you saw Popeyes Chicken
your chicken gonna taste disgusting
right you have to be a part of what you
do you know and I'm about to start a new
venture going forward and it was you
know a lot of questions was being posed
on what should we our market and what
should we sell and that's well I got a
whole thing that's coming up next year
and that's what I'm about and that's
what I'm gonna push forward on that and
the whole idea is if I don't support it
if I can't stand behind it I can't stand
for it and once you start just taking
the money then you can see the hollow
things that happens with a company and
you're not gonna get a genuine apology
because they don't think they did
anything wrong because they're so
disassociated from the situation well
also they therefore my understanding
solve and on dad you guys correct me if
I'm wrong like aren't they isn't there
like some type of Hong Kong attachment
to the coming of the Chinese owner
there's something more there that's
convincing but well there is tension
tension only 10 people unless let's just
get those likes up let's do that we got
we got a great acquisition here I'm glad
you are tuning in and this is a very
supported podcast right now at the
moment you see a dead set right that
must the word must have got a untell you
a famous two
let's move over here they're here for
the death stranding eventually we got
cupcakes first honestly I would say
$0.10 and I shot to dizzy says tension
only has an effect towards the Chinese
market though and I don't think that's
true anymore
I think Tencent has it's it's tendrils
and enough companies globally that
that's what makes it murky it what makes
it murky is that they own enough and
have enough power and the Chinese market
is is is strong enough that it would
make an American company sort of think
twice about how they say things what
they say what they allowed to be said
it's just a fact and you know they they
try to sidestep that and say that it's
not that when it absolutely is that it
all comes down to money
forget about forget about you know you
know the way the company feels forget
about what's right and wrong it's very
black and white and it's money and it's
always gonna be money fair enough are
you good on this well you know I said
everything like like sovereign said is
about the bag and the fear of the loss
of the bag um companies will not come
out and disrespect their partners now
the way another company that their
association with the views disrespect
and disloyalty can affect the bottom
line very severely right so because
you're dealing with different cultures
so if their practices are in line with
their partners but not in line with our
culture you see that's what the divide
happens because now they have to as a
company decide to side with their people
that they're selling that stuff to or
grab business partners then properly
kept them afloat when they were gonna
close the doors it's a it's a very murky
line and that's that's why we're gamers
we don't deal with that stuff you know
stop looking at the companies and let's
just sing some weirdo stuff and if this
is all individual you know that they're
weirdos
stay away from it no no you know and I'm
buying oh yeah I'm buying it was so
little let's face it people don't have
the education like the amount of people
I've talked to you they're like oh I'm
not supporting blizzard because they
take Chinese money which is fine I
respect that stance I'm shallow Epic
Games is 49% owned by 10 cents and
majority stakeholder hmm
so that gearbox the epic game store they
got 49% of that bag in their money it's
important to realize Ted said not really
a favorable company it's on record as
they are labeled by the United States
Pentagon as a terrorist slash fishing
wah website considered in the United
States to be an illegal company that has
no business doing business and you know
in the United States or North America in
general but they own a good chunk if you
look up in companies they're investing
by tensing you're gonna see almost every
one of your favorite developers has a
man is interested mammoths listen man
you guys nailed it I mean you know I
mean that part didn't interest me I'm
here for some some drama and some
overwatch smoke actually oh oh yo
overwatch Lords it's about time thank
you fans for demanding your go let's go
oh thank you fans for demanding more
from your franchise y'all know how
strongly I disagree with overwatch with
a game of the year multi player
bare-bones with no story but you know
what young on to something y'all asked
for a story that I am so proud that
y'all demanded y'all game of the year to
act to actually have a narrative to
actually have features that can kick in
your pieces oh I'm so happy
yeah Allah
because you know as a destiny fan all I
heard was there's no narrative and you
gotta go outside the game when the
grimoire and I am so happy I put that
beautiful trailer together with the cool
cinematics and shout to my man Genji who
saved the day you know I'm saying I was
very very emotional it got me going you
know
so salute to y'all so the game I played
as good here ninja I had to play Eddy
duty super that he blocked a joint I
know what I'm talking about
anyway salute to y'all you know say but
that does it all jokes aside it was good
to see the game looks phenomenal the
characters because that's the thing
about all watch the reason why I have
such an issue is just that in my opinion
they have some of the best tron card
they got characters you want to care
about yeah and I just wanted to know
what the hell the story is like what why
are they doing what they're doing and
that intro literally if they would have
had something like that I would have had
no issue with the game
I'd have been good so think about it
from like the TAM point of overwatch to
like there's a lot of things that's
confusing because they didn't have a
story you know like the fact that may
they're trying to introduce her is like
it looks like she's a new character but
she's not and I said cuz to me I'd be
dead good they're sitting on a gold mine
this the game is beloved out to my boy I
know he's married probably right now
Lord I gone to his condo Daniel man from
North gave me that Miss always kills the
overwatch articles and like I said I
just it's good to see because you got
people who really want to have that
emotional attachment and to see stuff
like that and so I'm going to say
they're gonna have a store you can have
these molds dad is so dope and then as
far as the arm Diablo for man what can I
say I mean Diablo is Diablo
it looked fantastic I know some people
had shot the poet as he had some minor
issues with it but um for the most part
yo Blizzard knew what they was doing man
like they they they knew a lot of people
going bending me real fast but they saw
it at overwatch too what's funny is is
there there's the biggest demographic
that likes to would cause stuff is PC
and they're like you know what week
some PC games for you guys so many
people died I need to know
hashtag we still broke a protesting or
not watch - I was done with that life
you put your pick it dad you're just a
lap oh man overwatch looks good I'll see
you guys inside I caught all the smoke
because I told someone you would have to
tie me to my gaming chair to make me
play Borderlands 3 and then like I game
share partner you got three I'm like nah
I'm not a man my girlfriend just broke
up with me I'm really sad I'm like there
you go there you go
game on it would have been like my
girlfriend broke a myth I'm really sad
I'll be like come play destiny with me
then I get on man I was on it for three
minutes and someone tags me a tweet goes
oh wait he's out here with their fraud
like a crime at the table I heard you
talk I'll be honest if you don't really
want to be mad at Blizzard for something
be mad at them for not bringing out any
new IP well when you got what you got
though we got too much in one I know you
know what money to not be making other
things but what is a banger dough I mean
it doesn't matter
we're about to get the sequel in two
years so I mean it's like Mike Ibarra
man because I know why he's a big
blizzard guy and I know why he went over
there you
say he's in pocket he loves Diablo you
don't say yeah first he gonna trust me
he's gonna have a lot of involvement I
know Mike pretty well he's gonna have a
lot of involvement with that stuff you
know wow he came from that culture these
are all besides definitely those games
are his favorite game so look look for
big things for Blizzard Kasab there's
too many companies making a lot of stuff
so just stick to what you know don't go
how to dip you tell someplace else do
you baby
I got on this anybody else left on the
Blizzcon
addict are you good can we move already
got anything else left for this topic
sir now I want to talk about this trend
I hope we go get one more it'll be quick
I have to pull I have to put my foot
down in this title it says boys card
then we do it we gotta do it it's me
I'll be very quick with consulship I'll
make it quick all right so listen
obviously I'm up so um yeah man look you
already know what time it is we're back
in the building we did x cloud last time
you know I'm saying now it is console
streaming so if you're a part of the
Alpha program you too can get in your
xbox and get it all set up so let's just
get it out of the way what the settings
are obviously gotta have open that
Bluetooth controller you gotta have the
latest firmware and I believe arm you
leave it on your ISP upload has to be at
least I believe nine megabytes per
second so that's the best experience you
can have
you can rally minimum you can do 5
megabyte per second upload but you
really should be doing now
Xbox must be in power on state for the
best experience
so um actually when it but it goes in
your xbox does turn on remotely um I
tested it a lot of times just to see
just be going around and when I came
back so what happens is your Xbox the
light is not on when you're doing this
let's when you're out in the field at
home your lot your stuff is not on so no
one's gonna know your Xbox is on the
only thing I would advise is if you're
like me who who puts like his xbox one
to turn on the TV to turn on all make
that stops off because it will act like
it's on and those other devices will
turn off so you have your party in your
house and you turn on your plate they
think your house is possessed
Oh No so please you don't say that's
that's it I think the only as far as the
UM the bad let's get the bad out out
first I mean all right in comparison I
will have done X cloud which is
streaming ties cloud you've got a
limited amount of games I believe for
games the game past games that were
there the gears you gotta gather this is
basically like King said remote
streaming so you are going to your
console in your house um off top I have
to admit just overall project X cloud
streaming I felt was a little more
quality you know I'm saying not buy like
a big amount but it's impressive that
the azure service to me I felt was a
little bit more responsive that's just
me I'm saying comparison against to just
to game test I believe destiny and out
of worlds we'll get into that so um yeah
overall look if you if you're familiar
with remote play from PlayStation if
you've done that it's pretty similar but
I will say it is slightly more
responsive um the cool thing and the
common denominator out of all this where
this surpasses remote play is you can do
this off a cellular so because remote
play you're locked in a game at this
time not like you oh I just want to make
that abundantly clear
oh boy let me get a shadow what it goes
place they should done this right no
they didn't they don't do cellular
that's the problem you have to be locked
in to Wi-Fi so that is not the same I
can go outside I can be in my car with
remote play you cannot do that I have
both you cannot do that so that's the
first thing and then obviously you know
the average oh I wanted to do with the
least common arm and 4G LTE you don't
say it's our destiny first fantastic man
I was able to key from me I felt was
sniping you know I'm saying from long
distance getting that range seeing if
it's accurate moving around everything
actually surprisingly the analog
movement solve a more responsive or
remote
reaming then it was X cloud now where
the difference is the X cloud
button-pressing is more responsive
because I felt like I was playing
destiny I was pressing to jump do my
wallet job
there was a slight deserted prediction
um software that's right so yeah overall
I guess I was moving around with it it
felt good it was kind of like the
opposite of them
the Xbox person next move it was tight I
did have no screen tearing no dents you
know saying so that was cool and um yeah
that I did um out of worlds I did out of
worlds that was fantastic
like that was literally one to one I was
literally playing a game the only thing
I would say they need to work on is they
need at this point which is coming they
got to get the API where you can um they
said they're gonna work it in where the
mobile screens will have the fonts to
being able to be a little bit larger
because playing out of worlds and you're
trying to read the text it's a little
it's a little tougher so yeah you know
what you are right now so what you do
gotta just purchased a new Ferrari you
just met her
I really don't like you know I couldn't
win the Ferrari - but I didn't you won
the Ferrari you lookin nice II have a
funny you telling me how I goes from 0
to 60 and hope I don't like you know it
is what it is but um yeah other
restrictions you have to became as
remote plane if you're on remote play
you cannot like try to open up your
YouTube or your movie apps they they
shut that down like that you not doing
no one guy TV none of that so they don't
have the license for that so um that you
know you gotta do that but other than
that look impressive tech really
impressed and the cool thing is you're
on the go so um you know you got you
guys want to see how they analyzed how
to get the party feet their party chat
features implement it because we know
it's there this is just a matter of the
setup and um yeah
man look if they notice them down and
they're able to get everybody's
different Android phone configurations
and salient configurations working like
Hamas was working it was it was flawless
man it really was impressive man so
salute to the team very impressive I
think as cloud is definitely on to
something and it's in beta right now and
like I said hopefully it should improve
as it gets closer to release so at it I
am done
you should be happy now oh this is kind
of combo topic would you a king or
whatever but on death stranded we had
some news out there first in a week on
PC you know say that I'll see it was
announced that it was coming to me see
so we got that going on and then arm
number two obviously the reviews the
reviews started to come out and we
started to see a lot of mixed reviews so
um I'm gonna bring this to Lord addict
first I guess them you wanna stop for a
sec you done different uh should we wait
around obviously you know it's out here
we let's start with the PC news first
you know that was very controversial
cloud tech topic a lot of people didn't
feel it was coming to PC and then your
feelings on the reviews that have
released so a new fight he got his mic
together wafers get his mic together
while he's doing that let's get more on
dead man
- stranded PC and the review what you're
feeling on his stuff man man this is
first of all the people that were
sitting there that were surprised that
was coming to PT y'all can't read from
2016 or 2018 and alright
- super chance I'm I started cut you on
there I'm dizzy three super turns oh wow
so you get you get the one that I miss
you get the one I'm as before dizzy who
did I miss no no one just popped up I
also days alright files of chat if you
easily triggered grab some tissues
before death stranded talk starts we
aren't accountable for what you get
emotional upset about let me get this on
the tour y'all Supertramp for me NYT
says you know why the cat daddy fat
snacks model assumes that destiny and it
needs to win game of the year so I can
enjoy the chaos some men just want to
see the world burn fun right now the
dead straining ones game of the year I'm
gonna lose my I can't say build in death
stranding your thoughts on everything
man it's it is what it is I don't know
why people are upset it's on PC I'll
never understand why people get upset
when games are on PC you want to play it
on PC go play it on PC I don't know
everyone actually canceled their
pre-order your fool and I knew going in
the reviews on those they're gonna be
divisive as hell like we knew this was
gonna happen
cuz there's gonna be people that are
gonna give it a hundred because it's
kijima there's gonna be people they're
gonna trash it because of Kojima and I
think somewhere in the Middle's the
actual truth of the matter and like we
every one could argue about video games
of the fun and all that other stuff but
at the end of the day this review kind
of where I thought it would anyone who
thought this is gonna do 90-plus need to
take the goggles off a bit this is
something that's never been done before
whether that's good or bad it's up to
people and I think this game is doing
something different
I don't celebrate for the fact that it's
doing something different mm-hm but that
doesn't necessarily translate to of
being an amazing game but I'm one of
those people that I use reviews to go
okay but the will i buy it day one
that's [ __ ] i'm gonna do by day one
I want to get the experience for myself
I need know if this game is good for me
because if I went off of reviews I would
never bought stay decay - and by the
state of decay - is one of my favorite
games to play
oh so reviews are great whatever if
kijima finds massive success with game
awesome good for him and that's just
kind of my thoughts on I know everyone
else on the panel is gone let's get Lord
BG in the realm always a pleasure to
have so much entertainment to you
because I must have been a huge fan of
your analysis when it comes to consumer
if certain things and I find it quite
unless you have some great videos up
just recently that caught it and let's
start first with the PC arm stuff
because you were very you had a very
entertaining video or net a reference to
people's arm reaction and canceling and
then let's get into the review aspect so
Lord BG the floor is yours that's random
man let's talk about I mean so y'all
hear me clear right yeah that was good
so as far as the PC you mean you know I
just did that to troll a bit number the
die-hard Kojima fans we address for a
cookout happy wasn't that video video
power bottles a little bit without no
you know what I like I like when he did
it joint when he was at work he was
actually put your hair for the video
like the you know cuz I just wanted to
it felt funny to see all the people who
were worshipping him for three years
suddenly turned their back on the
Masters on their masters those like you
know us it was like this is the slaves
finally opening their eyes and rebelling
and
only realizing they were slaves for
three years I'm like all right I'm just
I was just glad to see you know the the
uprising and the betrayal and all that
right could you betray people he was
honest as hell because he told y'all
what was gonna happen before it happened
yeah I was like no he's just chilling no
he was just telling you the truth and he
was arrogant enough to let you know he
was gonna do it before he did it
you still got caught with his super-move
told you he was gonna do the ha mija
mija he was like nah and he did it and
you got caught it's but it's it's
literally the whole thing about Depp's
training is like what blows my mind
about it it's like it's literally
somebody telling you who they are for
three years and you're like no that this
person is just they're just playing
around they're just joking and they they
like continue to tell you no no I'm
serious I don't I don't know what my own
game is about the game the game is about
hiking the game is about just traveling
delivering packages
you know the game does not get good and
so halfway through he said all of this
no this isn't this isn't these that
these are not my words like he's
trolling why first off why would you
throw your own fan base I don't
understand that you know it's what they
do joke leave trolling you know like
talking about something that's like a
joke in your community but like the way
these people are talking like they want
to be trolled by Kojima
yeah this this is this is why it's it's
like that um what do you call that
relationship where the abuser becomes
emotional exactly they be Stockholm they
could become emotional to their abuser
and this is what it is people like when
Kojima plays with people's minds
suddenly they they they're fascinated by
it I don't know why people are so fast
and it's go like whoa yeah you know what
it is when you got a whole bunch of
dudes that go to those little jazz
sessions and they go to open open mic
and spoken word and they all want to do
this finger snaps instead of
and I didn't want to all smoke and you
can smell incense and stuff you go
inside the room you looking at all this
weirdo energy and he's sitting there
like the cat jumped over them he wants
someone do the entire dead stranding
doing that you can't be and I'm telling
you it's when he got done moral deltoro
whatever tomorrow and he started putting
all these real true life actors in it
this is the space in the realm he wants
to be in he wants to be Hollywood Kojima
is the Asian version remember homeboy
from don't be a menace that was that was
too deep everything for the sake of bad
I got asked your question yeah I know
you going in what about those who say
yeah this game is just too deep like
it's just a work of art like like this
is this is and I this is abstract and
that not everything is supposed to be
easily understandable and this is an
issue with you as a gamer that all the
ones that's really on the Kojima Jesus
say that thing you said BG say that
thing they said about the art go get him
the whole thing about this game being
too intelligent and you know it's a it's
for intellectual minds this is like this
is that's the same premise that people
use throughout history to like brainwash
like that's best that's like stuff that
Jim Jones the most the the most craziest
dictators and brainwash and brainwashers
in history what that's the same tactic
they use you know making certain people
think they're lesser than others and
brainwashing you into certain beliefs
it's complete nonsense but I like Kojima
said he doesn't understand his own his
own game you know at least part of parts
of it you know everything is of metaphor
with him he's a like people think I'm
joking but he's a complete egomaniac all
right even to me is everything to him is
is making everything into a metaphor
he's alright
I do got a quick question and go around
real quick is there a such thing can you
give me a secret that we have to get to
as well okay let me handle that real
quick we got a $2 super check from Bratz
Kojima has a history of trolling the
fanbase that doesn't mean it's right
that means he's an idiot we'll keep
going on this all right so it's meld oh
no I got a $5 super chat from snail joke
regime is on something cuz death
straining still confuses me
hashtag PC master-race and welcome to
the IO Club but well welcome on dead to
that Opie Club all right so I do got a
quick question you know there's a lot
going on right now that is talking about
what I cannot believe I'm about to say
this
what do you is the definition of fun
because there's a lot of these reviews I
don't know if you guys have read the
answer yes but there's a lot of these
reviews that's trying to use the word
fun and make it something that's not mmm
and so I want to go around and just tell
me you know make it brief we don't want
to talk 20-30 minutes because it's get
really deep what is your definition of
fun BG and then we're moving around it
plain and simple even by the dictionary
Jeff in definition it's just enjoyment
and it doesn't have to be it doesn't
people people think it's this jovial
feeling it doesn't have to be it doesn't
have to be jovial you can you could have
fun you know listen some people will
have fun by giving other you know giving
other people pain like you know
torturing other people that's fun to
them it's fun but if it's it's just
simple enjoyment to you you don't have
to put it in quotation marks you don't
have to give it qualifier it's fun it's
fun it's not it's not rocket science
it's the most simple it's the most
simple three-letter word probably in the
dictionary and I think that's what
people are trying to try to go away with
it like look you can enjoy something you
could fear something you can hate
something but if it's done in a right
way it'd still be fun
that's the qualify for everything okay
when you go up just like what did you
think about this he's like you know it
was fun you know what I really enjoyed
about it like that's how they open up
these conversations but not with that
strategy then we'll get solving and then
like you know with the whole trolling
thing
people understand Kojima has CRO trolled
his fan base but it was always good
trolling like he he never told his game
to be negative like saying my game is 50
it doesn't get good until 15 hours is
that's that's a bad troll that says
you're you're trolling your game in a
bad way saying that you don't understand
your own game that's not a good troll
you don't say like when he told us in
the past about his games it's it's
always turned around to be good positive
or you know things that are good for the
game so it's not the same right very
very interesting right bad is definitely
a very polarizing game hi one of the
most polarizing I've seen a guy Greg
King and then I want to get solving yeah
BG said something in the video that I
was watching is you called him a bad
storyteller yes and I said yeah because
when you're purposely misleading your
fan base or the audience to a point of
confusion and they can't follow and he
lose interest in what you're talking
about because I saw a lot of reports or
faked interviews or whatever
review and they said that they won't
finish the game when you know into the
game I'm not gonna finish this mmm
you understand like I think you have
missed your mark
you have missed what you shot at and if
you shot at to keep the attention of
your audience by confusing them and they
decided to lose interest and walk away
from it that means that you lost half of
your audience there and I don't think
that's like you said and I said wow that
he said so poetically that he's a bad
storyteller do you he's a bad story
teller because his metaphors are on the
nose they're not deep they do art they
drive you hard like if you trying to be
metaphorical right and you name your
characters based on their actual
attributes
not being deep That's not me
people could people would think that's
deep yeah his famous I think it would be
fair to say that he's not a good
storyteller
just from if you are the game director
and you are own quoted saying you don't
even understand your own game I think
right there you can come back to the
drawing board look you you should have
some kind of concept what's going on in
your game and it always it hasn't always
been this bad like when you play Metal
Gear Solid 1 or 2 right there was always
metaphors in his game but each game he's
went more and more over the top with it
it's kind were staged game and the thing
is like like with the thing about it
being him being a bad speaker or well a
bad bad storyteller it's the same thing
with speakers like let's say someone
who's who gives speeches and they go in
front of an audience and they use a
whole bunch of language a whole bunch of
a verbage on metaphors and all this
wording that people don't understand and
that audience leaves your speech
confused who's gonna say oh man that was
a great a great speaker using great or
tater like no but for some reason we
think someone who leaves you be
bewildered and confused is suddenly a
good storyteller no you failed a fake
jeev is the Cassity of gave your
developers the figurative language I do
I do want to stay mm-hmm then I was
right about this game from day one my I
need my props I say we go get back to
the fun it goes back to the funds back
everybody thinks about fun differently
right like when I read the rules of this
game I immediately thought back to red
dead red that I'm the only person I'm
the ocean in games right I like the fact
that I could just walk run around Red
Dead and do stupid
little things that don't mean anything I
like inhabiting the world you can have
so when I saw exact that's not your idea
of fun I trying to I trying to comb the
the the pony the horse I I I hear that
and it's totally valid and fifteen
minute rides to the mallet as well which
is why I'd yet when I read the reviews
of this game I'm like I'm gonna be the
only one plays his game mmm
whether I like it in the end or not
because I'm not down for both for the
Kojima BS right all right maybe the
gameplay will draw me in somewhat we got
I know it's not for you guys oh let me
at this super chair five-pound super
trap from John donut a man I know I just
butchered your name but anymore go Mukul
move on we go act like they never
happened that launch trailer was the
definition of president's attention
pretentious I damn near rolled my eyes
into the back of my head when I heard
America is a lot of yeah look this is a
bit of vanity project straight up like
what about all right in in defense of
people obviously we are defense no but
wait a minute
none of us on this panel I played this
game let's be bowed out like this good
but let's be 1,000 right one none of us
have played so in fairness until we
experience for what we're doing right
now is we're looking at the reviews and
we're trying to formulate an opinion
based on reviews from a lot of people
who I feel like I feel like I I agree
with you on that but at the same time
when you read tin right I'm gonna get
that hold on I'm gonna get today I got
you I got you going that's what I
literally leading into that next point
which is the thing is we haven't played
it and we're gonna be fair right it's a
solves point the only thing I struggle
with and this is I think BG mention it
and you're about to mention addict is
that when I read reviews and you read it
and the first thing they say is you know
10 hours in I'm really struggling I'm
really bored what I hear terms like
boring slow pace that support the bad I
struggle with and i'ma tell y'all
straight I'm gonna jump in right now
he's like do I was in on his
nonsensical stuff in the beginning okay
this is a good troll I mean and
graphically let's not frame use argue
about right how's that graphically it
looked fire you know I'm saying hold of
dams I don't that's another super chat
my boy suicide kings if you read the
reviews the context doesn't coincide
with the high scores these sites don't
want to deal with the rabid fanboy so
you get games boring gameplay sucks
right I completely agree I would do you
think it's fair to say that this this
review actually should have been lower
like I feel like the Metacritic should
have been lower but some of these sites
are too scared to actually go in or I'm
gonna give you a say is that again when
I hear boring tedious and just more
importantly not fun when I see yo this
is not fun but if you get past 10-15
hours I struggle with that I struggle
with that like why do I have to survives
this game afforded that level of
endurance you know to struggle through
someone to get it that dad smiling so at
that point that was the red flag for me
as again I'm not trying to knock anybody
who wants to lose excited for it but the
number one there like I told you last
time when he did the Tokyo Game Show
review and he said for my hardcore
don't watch that don't watch this
one-hour gameplay of the core gameplay
loop right but don't watch that go but
you you you stay in pocket you got away
but for other people who have to know do
you know this is for y'all and then when
I saw it and this is for y'all and it
was literally balancing packages
traveling from one place to another that
gameplay loop did not excite me there
was nothing about that for me you know
I'm saying so I think that's what people
have to understand like that's where I
think it's very polarizing and then
obviously we heard what they say and I
get the end is like a two-hour cutscene
[Music]
but you know what we really need to
focus on what we'll really need to get
you know to really highlight right is
who the real MVP is I said it once I'll
say it again idea was the only company
that was like we ain't on the kijima I
have to say brap I cannot believe I'm
about to agree with you I cannot believe
I'm about to say I I will no ever ever
go about IGN about bias again I can't
say it any more
I needed them the most ways you needed
anyway gag kick I know you but you
bubbling there we go doesn't score the
hygiene point eight a six point what
turn right yeah
but they had different IGN America gave
him that then you had Spain himself give
him different giving me eight and nine
there was an epochal have one dude don't
want to be a rogue and want to put up a
wild number and then the rest of the
company puts up their numbers then that
rogue dude is looked at differently
inside the company I can't go by I don't
care about reviews let me tell you out
that straight off the racks alright um I
saw the game I'm a graphics [ __ ] I'm
gonna buy the game of ripped now Kojima
has gotten a certain level of cachet
with me off of the simple fact that he
has gaming memories in my head that I
can't get out and a certain level of
cachet has afforded him for me to go
purchase this game now when I'm telling
you this I know going in when I told you
I was laughing my throat baby when I
told you it was a UPS package delivery
service game when I told you Konami had
him in pocket and y'all was laughing at
me now that he's off the rails money
makes you more fool exactly who you are
the more money he made for that company
the more they allowed him to be who he
was at certain points in time they
probably told him your boy you gotta
stop doing that you're gonna that calmed
down a little because I know he has some
really far-out their thoughts well now
you see him loose he's running down the
block the emperor has no clothes and now
you're all upset with what you see by
this man don't be upset you have enabled
him for years you're the cause you have
made this rabid fan base that has
flocked to everything when that man said
that la Li Li Li la Lu how you were
supposed to look human very funny sir
I'm
the whole dog handler brab cohesive file
super chat that media bias
IGN spain doesn't count they have one
employee he was drunk off sangria so
pretty much we enabled this game with
him he is a rock star you don't put that
on me
listen if you if you've ever played a
Metal Gear game if you ever gave any
praise to Solid Snake if you played a
sneaking game here's the Godfather
sneaky game I enable could you know why
because he is the Godfather of that art
oh yeah we got Chris righteous the final
check young yang and skill up says the
game is great so it's really a game
you're gonna have to try to see if you
like it seems boring to me but I will
try it I mean it's you know at the end
of the day I see a lot of people trying
to tend the narrative of people that's
going at this game this has never been
about whether or not you know the game
is good whether or not the game is bad
this is this about the height the
anticipation this game got you know I
you know I've said some some crazy stuff
about this game I have but you know I've
never changed the narrative you know
it's 84 is a good score it was a great
score for a new IP mm-hmm but it's like
I said it's 84 a good school for what
these phase of putting this girl shut up
never shut up now books out the elf ugh
shatter stream team agreed Kojima is the
video games Kanye whoo yeah you know
because work is actually like on you
we're going off of his first album his
best lyrics
Wisco okay finally remember in him in
his heyday I got a question for you guys
what do you think even though they did
obviously announce a long time ago that
that stranding would be coming to PC
right obviously a lot of people didn't
remember that right so what do you guys
feel about the timing of the Rhian ounce
'men of that right right before
obviously Bobby would
remember it or no whatever the case may
be right before the launch of the
PlayStation version all right what do
you think about that time because for me
there's a couple of factors that make it
weird for me right the fact that they it
announced it in such a grand way before
the launch the PlayStation version right
right that's one - the fact is that this
game is built on a Sony engine on the
decima engine right and so honestly I
feel like and I know you guys agree
right it feels like when Sony and and he
got together in the beginning they gave
him that bag to make to make his game
right
somewhere in there they still sort of
felt he was going to be able to make a
game that would be financially super
successful and mainstream enough mm-hmm
like like a Metal Gear game is where
it's gonna bring back that money it's
gonna have the controversy but it's
still gonna be action II enough where
it's a game that they can mark it as
this PlayStation third-person
over-the-shoulder action game and this
isn't really that so yeah almost feels
like when they got the game back and
they're like oh this is what your game
is mm-hmm
it almost feels like there was an
uncomfortable conversation they're like
this isn't what we expected how do we
market this game or so you think you
gonna like with the recoup like they
like oh it could be they're trying to
figure out when they got the game back
and they've they saw what death
stranding is death stranding is
definitively not an action game per se
right
no and that my feeling is that's kind of
what they expected the game to be and so
it almost feels like Delta they're
having a little buyer's remorse it's
what it feels like let's get one card
and then let's get BG undead what do you
think about that comment man well the
thing that strikes it is weird for me is
the fact that up until this point like
we knew there was a PC version coming
and everything else was in the press
release via both the publishing side of
it is kind of weird because the games
being published by Sony Entertainment on
the PlayStation obviously but 505 is
actually handling the PC publishing side
right
which I don't can't think of too many
games that come out where it's a
kwang-ho console exclusive
there's a different publisher for the PC
version and the really weird thing to me
too is like the decima engine as well
it's like this is gonna be the first
time this engine goes on PC right and
it's being handled by a third-party
publisher kinda seems weird that Sony
would relinquish that or not want to get
the piece especially how they've come
openly said that they are open to
publishing games on PC too right yep and
that was one of the contentions from the
the fanboys that was saying that it
wouldn't go to PC because of the decima
engine from what I recall shout-out to
dizzy real quick to our super check
kijima has more Eagle than Peter
Molyneux Zulu obg what what about that
aspect with the PC version like a
reference what's obviously I mean that
it is a little bit on a stranger side
but I mean I don't you know I don't
really care where there comes to PC I
don't think I think it shows that I
don't think so he was like all in and
necessarily we're gonna like planning to
buy kojima productions or anything like
that they still wanted to see what game
he was gonna make because and well the
game he chose to make to me really shows
how like while this man and i brought
this up on press Start podcast when I
asked him I'm like this and and and I
said Kojima makes games for himself he
doesn't make games for the public he
doesn't make games the public wants he
makes games for himself and sees and
understands that he has a certain fan
base that is loyal to his type and in
and his loyal to his mind not even loyal
to his games is loyd loyal to his reza's
resume and he's like I could put this
out and I'm pretty sure there will be
people that'll buy and I'm like and I
said it I'm like I don't think
developers should make games for
themselves hmm
you know they shouldn't make games for
the what that the people want
specifically right like I understand
like you could you make games that are
that you're passionate about right but
you know but games that is literally for
you this is a game
that literally owned you you can the
only person you could be sure would want
to play this is Kojima they specifically
focus on the fact that it this game is
obviously him letting people know how
pissed off he was how he was treated at
Konami this this is one Wow
this is what this game is about in this
long roundabout dumb metaphorical way
like that's what it is
all right behold or shouted gate was
coming out as he said how we we all get
an L coz this is an 84 Metacritic we we
really getting out of 84 Metacritic game
maybe 84 84 84 is terrible 84 is
terrible for the y'all gotta understand
when you hype a game from the logo not
from the game you hype a game from the
logo because them simply because of who
was making it mmm you know you don't you
don't you're not allowed to get an 84
you're not allowed the media the media
that the general public who wiped this
game from the logo for three years no
you don't you don't get to get a 84
is it really an 84 know where people
scared to say something bad about your
name it's honestly definitely more of a
74 I think maybe it's probably like a 65
maybe he really passed you know and you
guys are sitting there y'all keep saying
all the gears listen this is not a game
versus a game let's let's stop that
let's stop pushing that narrative only
we're dudes that want um like some stuff
like that need to put up another game
against another game we're talking about
the game and then itself as in his whole
its itself and I didn't get a chance to
play yeah but I'm a purchaser because I
got my playstation 4 triple-a exclusive
titles this is a triple-a exclusive
title only to the PlayStation at this
moment next year's gonna come out for PC
god bless to any of you got taken out
for the PC that can run it god bless all
nestled dont fraud on there I'm gonna
wait to PC stop it you just don't want
to get the game but the fact of the
matter is when you play this game
you gonna come up to your own decision
on the game there's too many people
afraid to go against Sony at that as a
market leader right now to go against
kijima and as a genius in his own right
you know not to say that he's not bold
and he's not daring because he is right
and we do need that in our industry
you don't need everybody to be
straight-laced all the time he needs he
needs a system of checks and balances
because he was Metal Gear games are
right he still had a structure that he
had to work within sovereign let me ask
you this when you first left the company
that dejected you and threw you in the
bushes and your first freestyle album
out is gonna be what your first
freestyle album probably won't be good
because you're gonna still have all that
pent-up animosity that you built you
know this is not what was it I know some
bank and he has some wack stuff so this
is that album to get back after the
breakup okay let the man get his breakup
even even throughout the course of all
of his Metal Gear games right there's
still things from a gameplay perspective
and a storytelling perspective that he
just it's obvious that nobody's telling
him no man like you have to you have to
round this out in a way that makes sense
not it you can be try to be deep you
could try to be metaphorical but if it
doesn't make sense and then from a
gameplay perspective if it's not
mechanically functional right in a way
that makes sense those things need to be
addressed and that's what I feel he
doesn't have I feel he has a yes men
around him right
no it reminds me of you ever talk to a
little kid like a three-year-old right
like my nephew news3 is alright
describing something to you right little
kids will describe things to you in
exacting detail how they see it right oh
yeah you know like the rainbow and then
dragon came down from the rainbow and
the dragon was purple and green like and
then you know then the dragon came and
then you know he threw a fart what they
will tell you the story in the most
exacting way and that is Bhumika Jima is
a three-year-old and vomits stuff out
yeah that's what it feels old without
any checks and balances of hurt that
this man has endured you know you don't
know how he locked them for somebody
that built your company on on his back
or whatever you know Konami had a name
but he brought it to the forefront let's
not act like this man wasn't do a gold
watch he didn't get his own watch he got
a kick in the butt out the door so this
is his rebuttal No however he works out
the kinks yeah if he's gonna lose a
couple year
I mind my bet on this man is that his
next album is gonna be a thing we're
gonna get the super chance in a minute I
want you to get though I just want to
say like what about - sobs point to be
G's point in a sense of checks and
balances right they were controlling
right so what what if the relationship
worked because he's this creative beast
who so descriptive whatever but then he
had that foundation okay let's chop that
out let's not give them all it is let's
get it more to come okay that's not the
classics that we got into this maybe not
him by himself we don't get that same
level to this I say this justice league
all right we got Zack Snyder's little
chopped up cut because somebody decided
to do whatever they wanted to do but the
world is screaming for his full cut that
let Zach be the creative genius if he's
gonna go off the rails whatever is gonna
be let it happen right this is our let
it
happen okay listen let's give him this
Mulligan let the man have this Mulligan
let this be he'll mother and I but the
thing is he can have this Mulligan right
when the bride autumn line is that it
look good though
fine oh no graphics is your thing but if
there if the fun if the financial bottom
line isn't there at the end of the day
the bag the next game isn't gonna be you
think he's gonna make his money back
I think this is not as universally
appealing as metal gear is gonna have a
ton of them did we get the one about
dizzy yes I think no no we didn't get
dizzy all right so we got a $2.00 super
chap from from dizzy guys cuz Jima has
more ego than Peter I don't know who oh
no we got that we got that one we got
that one all right then we got a $5
super chat from Bratz Kojima has him
take your favorite portrait of himself
his bathroom they come propagated out
Kojima is the cannabis and over gaming
Wow yeah out here yeah I just don't know
again if because he's used to
alright now he's able to be weird with a
bag if Sony decides or whomever decides
hey like he's gonna start he's really
about him he's not gonna make a game as
universally appealing that's gonna sell
the way we wanted to sell back I'm gonna
be there
so now I was going to eat cuz he was
gonna be making weird indie games
because I'm telling you sovereign this
is where I know you're absolutely wrong
this game is going to sell honestly I
really think it's going to appeal to a
certain level first of all the certain
level of kijima friend is purchasing or
rip off of and then the collector this
is his first game in his in his company
on this platform so the collectors gonna
purchase like you know put it up and
just to show it off cuz you know
all right no first release on his first
solo project that he did you know I'm
willing to bet this is this game is
gonna have like legendary like a
legendary percentage of people who don't
beat it I guarantee you this whole
kijima thing happened and he left Konami
I think so and he went to him in a place
of weakness it's not necessarily you
know then being weak right but they they
wanted him in a place of weakness and
they're like look like we'll fun
whatever the hell you want to make right
I dig that and then Kojima is like
whatever I want to make will give you
millions of dollars to do whatever you
want to do I will say this I think I dig
it is gonna sell I agree with King in
this step because I can't front because
it's so polarizing oh yeah like now
there's people that want to know what
the hell's going like do you agree on
there like do you think that like
because of all the controversy that is
going to directly affect sales or you
think that you're one of the cats out
the bag do think and Iraqi look I'm
gonna say this I think people need to
keep sales expectations in check this is
a I I don't mean this is a knock against
this game this is just a really hard
game to like sell - you're like brother
who plays call of duty and Madden I
don't think I could sell this to the
homeless dude beside the dollar store
good teams coming out in one of the most
crowded release schedules this year I
think this game will be a sales hit in a
spring or summer window I think it's
gonna have a hard time coming off the
backs a call with duty and heading right
oh come on time when another thing
there's living but they went when Zod
was he really was octo was it what would
see how do you release my brief on
November all right we got no we have we
have full black Fridays we got who else
you got it
we chose to go for the bills at it all
right so we have a fight I was super
chat from cat daddy mm-hmm
he says last one I think most of these
cats cancer their pre-order for clout
they probably pre-ordered it to play on
throwaway account recipes risk is I
guess that's that's a football team yeah
your Friday night through Friday night
for you for that I'm not reading I read
the bags with Lord dirty deed shout out
the Canadian brothers he said I shout to
the podcast to show as big as RDX for
real great show every week love from the
frozen north Yellowknife in the building
are dead you know say keeps pretty true
but continuing daily I interrupt you bro
III don't know like des [ __ ] is a hard
sell did anyone see the Rick and Morty
yes
that's hilarious I have to admit when
everyone's out here saying if you don't
like that strain is because you're not
intellectual enough to understand and
then they come out with a Rick and Morty
at four and I'm like okay there's a
little bit confusion on what
intellectual means yeah so the question
do you think is going is going move it's
not gonna weigh MPD its move the gate
but I don't think this is gonna be one
of the ones where its top 10 best
selling games between 1900 head first I
want to ask the chat put a 1 if you
think it's gonna sell well put a 2 he
takes in a cellar right put it 3 if you
think he's just gonna flop mm-hmm and
question to the to the realm mm-hmm what
does it sell in the first week I just
got a no to competition all I know is
home Jedi fallen order right what else
is in November be Jedi fallen order I
mean look like when you look at the
other even when you compare it to like
the other you know stone so many major
so many games I mean bruh it's it's it's
not outselling spider-man it's not
outselling got a war it's bra I don't
even think it might have sell days gone
days gone I don't like
I don't like things going but I don't
think it's gonna outsell day long
BG I think it's gonna be day long
bro-bro people people have people loved
that zombie theme young don't know the I
know this right but like yeah I don't
think it's gonna outsell days oh no I
feel you on that I've seen okay you know
what it is I've literally seen a person
turn into another person standing next
to me trying to find this man mm-hmm
I and is weird they even say it but she
was nice she was cool everything was
great we went inside the store to buy
the Sony stuff you know her husband her
soon-to-be husband was there and you
know we all shopping together we're
having a great time and the fact that
Kojima was rumored to be on site there
was a $500 statue right there that I saw
her calculating in her head how she can
get the $500 to pay for said statue she
almost cried when they didn't have a
shirt in her size and the dude found it
in the back and then they went around to
find this man tooth - to figure out
where he was that because he was like
leaving a little cookie crumbs on on
Twitter whatever the hell he was like
I'm in this area and it was taking
pictures listen I saw her turn into a
huntress to find this maze of rabid fan
base that I listen when you got Geoff
Keighley
in pocket and in your game when you got
movie stars you got Norman Reedus and Mo
del Toro and girl look at Colin Conan
O'Brien in this game like I don't I
can't bet against this game I'm just
saying I don't know beating man on the
new IP but I won I'm very curious to see
which where lanes vs. Jedi fallen order
and the rest
I think abuse yet I've fallen order no I
don't listen no I don't think it beats
Jedi formal order for the simple fact
that the new Star Wars is Disney's
launching the Mandalorian
and the new Star Wars movies coming into
some no this is looking like to be one
of the you know the better Star Wars
games we've had and probably they even
made a wacky no chucci love how he
changed up from that we're rocking and
rolling with this joint let's keep it
pushing but uh yeah very polarizing game
we shall see what happens but uh Lord
King man is going on real quick man Xbox
all-access program what's going on out
here you know I'm gonna catch out later
I got it IBG alright little Yugi thank
you for coming through the other brother
appreciate you if y'all don't see his
two videos yell please right now he
Wales later tonight please support their
brother and please l broke games HD I'm
always much love in the realm my bro
make sure you check out those two videos
together right now we're the one with
him in the office I had to pull over and
watch it with go supreme because I
almost crashed my feces of foods to lose
Xbox man we got deals alright so um the
specific dates you know I'm not a
specific sky because this really doesn't
apply to me but this applies to the most
now what we do in a vacuum as human
beings we assume that other individuals
are doing the same exact thing that
we're doing which is not true all right
so that's the preface this what's going
on Xbox is releasing a new program
called all access right now all access
is an incumbent feature just the same
way that you go to get yourself on now
mmm-hmm not many people have consoles
but you can't really tell a do without a
cellphone right so not everybody goes
inside the store and purchases a cell
phone all cash out right now I don't do
it I don't know who does it I don't have
a thousand dollars to go inside and let
me go get the new Galaxy S 10 plus I
don't well so usually I get on a
subscription service you know playing
to pay it off with the warranty and at
the end of the year it's over in two
years or whatever it is and then you
usually trade your phone in and upgrade
it to the next model right
right because I have a buyback program
actually Samsung just sent me that now
so I'm Gary sending my ex what is it s9
plus I'm gonna go get a ten because they
give me free earbuds okay great all
right so Microsoft shout out to Phil
Dominus
Maximus Spencer and his in His divine
wisdom has devised a plan for those
individuals that are financially
cash-strapped that are in a position
where they can't support two ecosystems
but they want to indulge they are at a
point where they trying to make ends
meet and situations are at a point where
they only have certain amount of money
to make it happen so what if I told you
for $30 a month I'll give you the most
powerful console and to do the Morpheus
thing man what if I told you I don't
think we had one from the Cedric he
thank you for the $10 Supertramp man you
should have put supped in there man we
we encourage you if you put that money
we want we want you to say something but
anyway we got a $5 super strap from
shrinking kingdom you told me go ahead
switch the Solomon if they know you got
to spend it with the boss though you
told me guess we just dial up if they
hate the letter wait and watch everybody
follow look my skin's a little bit too
white I'm gonna go ahead and let you
read that sure you like that all right
so my trash box done and my delay
station for cuz they don't have
exclusive switch appreciate all of you
for coming up there hit that like button
you don't mind let's try to get it above
a
look at around listen lady Luke you know
what you know what they'll look if you
don't have an Xbox I guess we can't
finish that rage I guess I'll stay on
peace don't worry about it filled
ominous Maxima Spencer has something
father
now for the low low price of $30 a month
oh you get when you walk in the door you
get the most powerful console right now
the most powerful console nobody can
ever say it's not because it is it's a
fact don't feel that rub that in your
chest No
plus we give you two years of game pass
for free with it so actually it pays for
itself if you do the math on gaming pass
over the month you're actually making a
killing here so but get this I know
you're like king but why would I do that
and scholars get raid come out because
they have a buyback program if you give
back the console in working order you
can upgrade up to the Scarlett so all
that stuff all that progress that you
put in and you know Microsoft ecosystem
travels rensil travels from this system
to the next because they actually do
backup at you can actually take the disk
and put it inside from Xbox I'm
regularly xbox OG inside Jack's box and
you can actually play these games listen
people what what a real true leader does
he doesn't divide the community he
unites the community he also makes it in
a way that you can get down and be
affordable remember when I told you that
a boss that's who did that for you you
know Cognito I think you're onto
something what you have to understand is
a true boss a true king a true leader is
going to make sure that he takes care of
his followers
so if financially you can't handle the
burden of making that leap forward he
just made it easy
for you so if you thought I might not be
able to purchase scarlet and you know I
do have my regular OG xbox and I do want
to watch 4k movies well he can do that
for you right now and there's other
tiers to it you don't have to get an X
upgrade to your s well as little as
$19.99 a month so let's break it down
let's break it down let's get we got the
Xbox one we got to say all did you do
addition we got the shot my bad to
Sharda you are correct the Xbox game and
we got Jeff between I was a mom you know
they're coming in with the console to 24
months of Xbox game pass ultimate and
then the 18 month on what you call an
upgrade option and then you got the s20
$2.99 a month same kind of a deal and
then you can get the ex believe for 30 a
month 24 months again game pass ultimate
and like King you said they're doing the
upgrade option so I believe limited time
after this well that player 10 months
before you can reading that up for the
score project's guys that's like that
guy okay so after seeing that you can
see that when the skull is gonna be
released and you guys are a first in
line to get your hands on a Scarlett you
send it back and working order
you get yourself a Scarlett you into the
next generation with your 200 games plus
because game pass is growing daily now
remember this is the caveat all first
party games are released in game past
the level of entry to get you in he has
lowered the threshold no longer do you
need the 500 $600 plus money to buy
games if you was to actually go to the
store to purchase this bundle with those
200 games you will be well over two
hundred to three thousand dollars here
sir
so what you have to understand for the
low price of $30 fold to 1999 to three
dollars may give it away they give it
away I don't feel comfortable because I
should be paying full price for the
system I want a pocket watch it's your
choice you can go to the store and spend
$600 for the game and you can buy the
controllers you can do all
that stuff but for the conscientious
gamer for the game of who wants it all
for the game who actually is really
gaming and not frauding because I've
never heard someone say actually I did
on my timeline I heard somebody say I
don't want budget games for a dollar I
need full money and I don't appreciate
this king
I want a pocket watch right so port I do
wanna you know say this real quick he
says this is Microsoft nicking us to
death with options like so so at one
point at what point in time do you
actually become a game and stop frauding
at what point in time what does this
company have to do to you to show you
that they are doing you a serious fan
service no games now when you go out and
you go to the next generation and you're
going to go purchase your consoles I'm
telling you look at what the companies
is doing for you I'm not telling you
don't buy Sony
I'm buying it I'm not telling you don't
buy a Nintendo I'm buying it but you
know what I'm gonna do right now I'm
gonna take advantage of this my son
doesn't know for the Solstice I'm going
to purchase him a sad Edition so he can
get his Xbox one so he can play his
destiny so he could have his fun and
then I'm gonna trade his joint in for
Scorpio five humming of garlic I'm gonna
trade his joint in and I'm gonna give
him my Scorpio all right so you're gonna
have an X but I'm gonna get that scarlet
Edition because I'm gonna be first
online on the transition and I'm gonna
take advantage of the 200 games you get
a chance to play that I don't have to
come out of my pocket for let's get on
dad let's get solved you know obviously
the Xbox All Access program has been
believed actually is returned so what do
we feel about this undead did you know
is did you feel it's good value for
gamers what do you feel about
Microsoft's strategy leading into next
gen look
I worked 60 70 hours a week to pay my
family for what they need and everything
else I'm a single income family it's not
a lot options out there for you to
purchase like I broke my back to get
myself a potato gaming computer PC I
bought my original Xbox one used I was
blessed enough to have friends like
anchorman to help me oscillate to and X
to Lou I worked 80 hours a week to buy
myself a Playstation 4 slim so it's a
struggle when I need to upgrade hardware
we always talk about accessibility and
video games we talk the Xbox adaptive
controller we talk print subtitle print
size we talk all these different ways
accessibility is not only in terms of
physical accessibility it's also in
terms of financial accessibility chipra
mm-hmm and you know as someone who's
sing here regretting I don't have a
switch I can't afford a switch it's just
not in the cards for me if they had
something like this where I can put away
fifteen thirty dollars a month and have
a switch in my home and I can play those
games that's not a bad thing like if you
have the financial ability to go out and
buy a ps5 day one to buy a scarlet day
one with your bag of money more power to
you but to lower the entrance fee so
more people can play games I don't see
why this is a talking point at all this
is just great in an all-around fashion
and you know what if PlayStation came in
with it I would applaud them if
designers came out with it I would
applaud them for it making gaming more
accessible for people it's the same
thing I've always said with Xbox game
pass I've got a friend
homie only gets twenty hours a week at a
part-time job there ain't nothing in
this town for anybody but you know what
I bought that man a year's worth a game
pass and so he could play games all the
different time this man got to play
Devil May Cry 5 through Xbox game past
cuz he couldn't have afforded that and
he's happy he's enjoying his time while
working two three different jobs to make
ends meet without having to drop the
full price of games
I don't see an issue with that that was
just where I said I did I'll you caught
the king said if I'm not confident in my
product I'll be doing the same with xbox
Xbox had a little confident that's why
they doing all these deals are they what
do you say to that if you know what if
they don't have any confidence in their
products I don't know why you know out
of worlds and gears 5 we want to talk
review scores they reviewed well all the
Sun those all those people they were
like oh we only get double a $1 games I
just want to point out the outer world
score tired the deaths training car so
we got a $5 oh I got a fight on super
jet from w WD FC podcast Death Star
looks to be made for you guys can
definitely so that's Phil oh my god I
can't keep up Jedi fall in next a great
show of my iron Lords Congrats Ned no
damn sure shout the game was by choice
with the 2000 subject thank you Lord for
such an awesome show and being great for
the gaming community
I enjoyed the shows I get news and
laughs hit the light while salut but
that means a lot so if you want to get
the next one from braaap braap jack king
of stop saying his name like a machine
gun
King Phil hustling us you don't need an
Xbox console anymore you need is Boost
Mobile x5 in game and you know what
you're onto something
let's see what you just I love that
breath that you are with and imagine
that with came past to listen with
comedy he just told you the barriers are
being broken and shackles is being taken
off now what happens if game pass has
gained cloud X cloud in it when that is
all incumbents thing mm-hmm and you're
playing wherever you want to play I love
the fact that undead expressed that you
know financially it's not in his card
right now to have us a switch or to do
certain things and listen this is coming
from a person that can purchase
Devil May Cry
I waited and game pass rewarded me you
know so just the same experience the guy
that he has his friend that he knows was
played the game I was elated to find out
the devil made crocodile of devil may
cry but my backlog was so crazy I
couldn't say to myself I'm gonna take
$60 purchase a game and let it sit on
the shelf like I did with Zelda and I
want to get in society's Elda right now
but it was all fitting game passes so
let me get into it let me play it real
quick thank you and then I move forward
mm-hmm don't fight somebody said they
don't have no confidence in their games
and that's a boon for you let that
confidence fall to the floor you pick
their confidence up you pick it up at
the low-low
why would it be a problem for you
worrying about if they're making money
let them go down if they're not making a
nickel and you are winning why are you
complaining that you're winning mmm I
just I get confused with like why people
get upset when there's deals beneficial
for you like is just confusing like with
the gamers in this generation get more
upset the more accessible things are for
other people
isn't that like wait like it don't you
not people to enjoy a product don't you
want any weirdo energy still a part of
this community where it's it's like like
King said earlier in the show you know
we all came from being made fun of for
playing video games in place and now
it's becoming more and more accessible
to more people and some people still
have this energy like no no this guy may
fund me in high school yeah yeah yeah
like the thing was like we don't know it
when I went to high school I was on the
football team everything else but I
played video games I didn't tell anybody
on the team I don't know I ain't telling
them that was all about like Baldur's
Gate like I've got a nephew who's in
high school now and they sit around
pregame and play Nintendo switch that's
a beautiful thing
umbrella people playing games means more
game sales more game sales means more
game preach what is wrong with that
picture
exactly people I think I get an
exclusive culture and a lot of other
things just really contributed to it and
I just think it's an antiquated way of
thinking like people are gonna be in a
king you talk about this offline there's
gonna be a rude awakening next
generation when a lot of people's
favorite game companies are going to be
following suit with what's going on now
you're starting to see the evolution to
change I'm I'm happy that PlayStation
now drop the price down and including
first party titles and today's stuff and
hopefully the trends going fo it shows
them date and date shows they're giving
different type of services shoulder I
want them to adopt this economic program
where they can get the PlayStation 5 to
you because I don't think a lot of you
guys y'all think y'all ready for six
hundred five hundred dollars now think
you're ready for but when it when the
times come let's say god forbid you lost
your job at that point you can't afford
it you didn't put the money away or
something tragic - your car broke down
and you have to have money that real
life happens so if you had to go
purchase cellphones at full price not
too many y'all be waving around a new
part of it you know you you have been
using services to pay off stuff you have
been financing things forever so when
somebody tells you you're financing a
console or something now now it's a
problem don't do that
just because your company
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we got a 5 dollar check for breath is
nice is nice the barriers are coming
down more access to gaming grows 2 pi
yes definitely one Delilah we have a
2007 Delilah HD exactly braaap Xbox is
futures very bright and Xbox game pass
is part of that equation
make no mistake console dedicated
hardware is still extremely important
regardless content is king hashtag ex o
19 Castle Delilah me saying that
statement Xbox future is bright put
these dudes in there feeling overall man
like how you feeling normally when it
comes to consoles you know usually have
a good amount of time to I usually have
them paid off at Gamestop months before
they come out but you know there's a lot
of people you know I'm single I've got
no kids so you know I have a little bit
more extra cash than your average Joe
definitely nothing like Lord King over
there
you know well I like you know like you
guys always make fun of me over the next
thing it's like as the X didn't come out
day one actually came out day one I have
an X and I could have picked up an X for
a hundred and fifty dollars yeah I just
don't you know I got a PC now so I don't
really need an X so no - out the Lord
dirty D with the $2 Chad MC kitkat this
man the hat thing right but sideways
roll you out here me don't let no one
tell you otherwise
oh here's nothing you see what you
joined you see the realm real brief my
my only my only beef with the way that
they are they sort of message this is
that they sort of message it very
quietly like we did out there oh [ __ ]
let's preach it out there like they
really need to get out there especially
now that the big thing the big
motivating factor is you can upgrade to
next-gen hardware yes that's sovereign
you know what I think I think they don't
really want people to know too much
might not have enough Scarlet's to go in
yeah when you know that the Xbox sales
at the end of this year this Christmas
it's not gonna be great hardware wise
for anybody except probably this wish
right everybody's think about next gen
so I mean honestly like they're not
thinking about that do what you can do
what you can this episode is already in
class laughs fellow shadows Yoda
smartest the host cog leaders should
draw grow a beard and call the podcast
yeah I'm at beards podcast he's doing
beards are everything I can't compete
you got
solving the bushes on that once pick a
hair on your head do I really need these
well I'm seeing now is I'm seeing three
guys with beards and two guys that don't
got the scruffy on I don't let it grow
exactly and I just get ingrowns in my
yeah that's not good I'll wrap this one
up um Savio definitely on to it like
look no upfront cost like this is this
is tremendous value tremendous is gonna
really help remedy a lot of people who
on the fence who just couldn't get in
and like like I just said not everybody
is running out the window with multiple
systems and stuff like that and they may
want these games so like this is great I
gotta speak to Matt piscatella
from MPD we had them in a round before
because I want to make sure I want to
know if anything brought through this
all access program counts as a
traditional MPD console sale I'm very
curious to see how that's reported on
but regardless to what like oh they
gotta promote this they gotta promote
this heart if they make more gamers
aware I think the Amazon move was
tremendous because this way like
everyone's one at Amazon Amazon Prime
you jump in there I believe UK is
definitely on about it and they're gonna
be trying to do more regions and stuff
like that but um look if they promote
this thing this is a perfect way to set
up the next generation to get people
invested in the Xbox scarlet system
filled ominous fan you might be onto
something man we got it we know what
else you know what else you know what
else is nice lord Cognito
oh it's just just this motion that you
know nothing about
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we don't what we went up into last week
you do not ever have to fret I say this
for other people as well two of the most
rabid countries for Xbox are Brazil and
Mexico they have some of the most rabid
and passionate fans and a lot of these
programs Xbox is putting out is not
accessible in Canada Mexico Brazil I
understand you got rolled these programs
ain't slow but we're your biggest fans
are the people they're gonna talk about
your stuff are you got to get it to
those people but I gotta tell you this
and it
you said the rabid fans are there maybe
those systems already sold there and
they'd seen a level of plateau and
they're trying to get to the regions
where they didn't with Sony hit first
early remember Sony made a bones going
everywhere
Microsoft concentrated on a couple of
locations while Sony decided to spread
out the world give it to everybody and
then they already made the pipeline so
what you want to do is establish a
pipeline to get that current base
already established so then you know
your demographic
can you know your market going forward
and those are the guys you send the
emails to listen pre-orders is up right
now you can send the Xbox through make
sure that it is in working condition you
can go down to these stations and stuff
like that so you don't want to preach to
the choir you want to preach to the
peasant on the corner you want to get
him into the church you don't want it to
preach to the people that's already in
the church once they they're ready
they're they're ready for the sermon you
want to get that flock to come inside
that's how you grow your congregation
and we all know the mistakes of with the
Xbox one would the connect the limiting
happen in this time baby you know
hopefully they left less but I agree
with Undead
they do need to get candidate up just a
shout out those and mockers out there
he's repping you know I'm saying like
they really need to also New York I
don't got X cloud I don't feel that
sorry anyway be sympathetic King last
topic so we roll out of here man did if
we jump in a time machine back all the
way back to 2011 EA decided that they
were going to walk away from valve at
least and mostly in part apart from the
sins upgrades or something like that
they've walked away exciting that steam
has adopted a set of restrictive Terms
of Service which limit how developers
interact with customers to deliver
patches and other downloadable content
no other download service has adopted
these practices those are their exact
words and from that was born origin now
fast-forward to 2019 my feeling is steam
is crawling back and forth on their
knees giving gabe newell all the knees i
think we need to get back on steam and
how are we gonna get back on steve well
yeh access is probably the best way to
get back on steam so they recently
announced that they will be back on
steam starting with pre-orders which are
already up for jedi fall in order um
probably one of their biggest games
probably it will be their biggest game
of the year apart from fifa ultimate
team whatever whatever they make in
terms of money wise and i think i mean
it's only positive for
is right but I have to have to believe
that they did this for a couple of
reasons one obviously financially it
makes sense right they need to they need
to get as many eyes on Jedi fallen order
spots as possible and I think that comes
from pressure from Disney and from
gaming in general to stop isolating
their games to a service origin which
works fine but when they've had missed
opportunities with mass effect when they
Manhattan two days with battlefront but
they've had missed opportunities with
what with anthem you don't create your
own storefront and isolate your games to
that unless you have bangers first came
up with origin people were like you know
what they can make a sustain it Nick is
sustaining with all their games as a
service with all the games they have
coming down the pipeline they can
sustain it but you know fast-forward all
those years and the real is the reality
is that now they're people think of them
differently and isolating their games to
origin on PC is only a detriment to them
and I think ah I think did me point to
them and said you were not gonna do this
to fall in order you're not with as many
sales as we expect to get with all the
hype around Star Wars so I think it was
a matter of the Disney blue on the neck
realizing that this has to move forward
and them making the proper and right
decision to go back to vow we're gonna
have a disagreement
Oh before you disagree please get that
super chatter addict so we got a $10
super chef from JD gamer so many folks
holding onto the console for gaming but
if you want to know the future look to
the children what are they playing it on
they're playing it on iPads and iPhones
wool phones in general X cloud and game
pads yeah you know it's like I said from
the start you know you're onto something
JD gamer because you know when you have
that platform and you're able to just
you know pop it in your phone get that
code do the Bluetooth get your phone and
your controller and you can play stuff
on
pass for $10 a month you know it
definitely works out but you know
besides the fact I don't think this I
don't think this is any a thing don't
you Dave I think this is a steam thing I
think I think steam guy hit so much
losing all these first part all these
big third party triple-a titles that's
going to you know epic your framing
obviously I think it's you know mutually
beneficial right I think it's a middle
ground thing but I think steam if I were
to put money in something I think steam
reached out first
let's go undead man what do you think
about this whole thing you think he
invented me think it's just more
business with steam to compete like what
you out with this
oh let's face it steams been
hemorrhaging games massive like it's
been massive split though mmm cuz if
they change their policies on how they
split money but then I say steam won't
do it so steam just gonna have to keep
holding that l like steam refuses to let
go the the more the part so what's going
on here is they're having to reach out
to the people that like just think about
it they abandon their own platform you
know and you know what I really find
interesting is the fact that EA access
is on Steam now so now they have to get
there to give whatever they discount
have to not you even just a discount but
they have to give the discount on their
store and epic EA has to give them a
percentage of that subscription fee so
you know like I think there was a middle
ground
I think steam got to the point where
they lost control they lost Borderlands
they but I mean I can't even name all
the games they've lost
what's the outer worlds you know they
are been losing the majority of the
triple-eight times this whole this whole
[ __ ] this whole year I mean right dead
is coming out on Epic before Steam I
feel you yeah I get that right you that
clout from having the triple-a game
on there but I just think we'll money
perspective I still think the bottom
line isn't effective that much I think
the look of it it doesn't look good I
think I don't want to I don't think that
effect I think they're still making way
more money than that because but at the
right at the bottom light it's like you
said the perspective is there's there's
very few games on steam that's why I can
do a big yeah that's right like you look
or you look at you looking tweets on
comments on tweets all you see is this
going to epic Cisco an epic Cisco an
epic please say this ain't gonna epic is
it's going to epic that's training
that's training I guarantee you that's
going to epic because if you look at
their tweets they will litter they've
been answering every question about that
announcement but when someone asks is
this go to the epic game store they
don't answer that 100 say look the thing
is I want epic to I and I think we're
starting to see it I want the industry
as a whole to grab seem by the throat
and choke them my name is Eddie can I
prove that mess I want yeah I want Tim
Sweeney to put his boot you need to make
half-life 3 you need to make left 4 dead
3 you need to make games again and I'm
not talking a trading card game I'm not
talking to you need to make what made
valve great again great but like just
from the king what about from the spirit
of competition right like these duels
Gus these this stomachs is boiling
they're good in the funny thing about
this is you know people talk about oh
well that's not competition I'm not I'm
not supporting something like that but
Netflix
they do it all the time like you have to
compete like sometimes you have to hit
up NBC be like your stuffs coming to
meet only listen like like he had a room
in the house and that's front there's
this enough front II access and Orion
and that stuff is it was like the third
wheel on your car you know the only
reason why I still got EA access and I
forget to delete it is when a new game
is announced I'm like damn I still got
that thing and you know or when they
charge your account right so I paid for
the year so I got a whole year to forget
and then I remember when they say $35
listen they decided to cut costs maybe
they can shut down that one room they
can save money on that they not using
knees and doing this and running that
backdoor stuff over there this is
cost-effective so the money that they
save and not running these services over
here yeah they actually don't lose
anything when they go to steam let steam
do all that
this is the same way you selling stuff
and you have Amazon shipping your stuff
it's the same exact thing you're just
allowing another company to do this for
them but the question I have for y'all
real quick and I'm very curious is what
happens now with origin access is that
is that still gonna be a thing now that
they're over on Steam like what happens
are they bend in the knee and fold is
probably it won't be like the ubisoft
thing they're both there well my
question when you watch something on
steam that's EA is gonna boot up origin
okay so wait you think it's just uh
they're gonna keep status quo with their
launcher they're gonna still have that
like well that's how you that's how you
be soft is if you buy something off
Ubisoft off their launcher it boots up
their launcher to boot the game got you
so pretty much status quo is just been
the need let's put it on they just want
the biggest platform the biggest library
that's all they care about they want it
that's all the steam there's no denying
there's no boy . you like the steam the
the PC users they have that rope around
steam destiny goes from Blizzard esteem
and it's it went huge on Steam so you
know it is what it is if you want to
sell to as much as you possibly can on
PC you got to put it on Steam they got
you a to the fifth guys a sig is out
here yeah look
wrap it up real quick oh yeah I'm at
competitions good competition is good
you already know I feel about it
so ano they out here that big it's
definitely a lot of pressure on people
and steam has kind of responded you know
I'm saying we got the Destiny joint and
I'm saying it was announced over there
Microsoft's putting in their first party
games over there the exclusive is look
this is good at the end of days good for
gamers competition is gonna let them all
fight it out we win that's all I got
unless anyone else got anything else and
we'll roll show buddies we roll it we
roll it I there was a long one and shout
out to the technical difficulties
earlier new il peephole with the recent
mostly positive reviews of debt
stranding being released do you think
it's possible for a game to be not fun
slash boring yet still rated highly
because of its narrative the choices are
a no media bias kijima is an industry
darling adesh branding proves that they
don't hold them to the same standards B
yes kijima is a unique artiste
don't comment until you play the game
yourself see I don't care
Qaddafi was definitely onto something
those are the choices please write I
hope you vote when it goes up Lord
undead of Lords of gaming well next
round absolute pleasure to welcome him
in the room beautiful things special
things will be happening 2020 we looking
for a fantastic year and beyond the
pleasure to have you in a realm where
can I find people find you what else do
you have going on sir well you can find
everything I write on
you find them here going to give down it
continues here promo you fire me on
Twitter at undead 3x VI you probably
have me blocked we go set it up if you
got him block stay out your feelings if
you if he was black before him black now
[Laughter]
let's call me I'm all about that life I
can't destiny let me jump in the back
maybe all about jumping in the
background they got a story never gonna
play the stories look I've carried lord
anchorman in my backpack for three years
across these gaming streets carry your
backpack off show 'let's in this Tito
Twitter undead 3x there are you two bond
dead 3x Vig gave me perspective podcast
with mr. Samuel Tolbert Aaron Jackson
and radii range you spout off our
nonsense on a semi-regular wait when x
time it goes live every friday now at
five a m-- eastern time since we're
pre-record but slowly but surely slowly
but surely I'm figuring out this OBS
nonsense and we may start returning you
a live show format again but no doubt
baby please keep it tuned for that
no now please support my brother in the
roaming is out there positive brother
doing a lot of great things for the
community and again once again I did
again all jokes aside really
appreciative of you joining the Lord's
and we really look forward to working
with you on our journey so salute to you
brother this was we gonna make some
magic happen man for real so what yeah
Lord
egg sleepy attic with the beard Lord
KitKat on the brakes 1 & 2
baby let's get it I'm not answering
today Lord addict first off I want to
appreciate everyone coming to the it's
kind of my I'm literally speechless I
don't even know what to say maybe it's
cuz I'm tired but I doubt but you know I
appreciate everyone coming through
you guys are extremely generous at the
super chaste today I you know I
definitely appreciate that you know
being lord King working on some members
stuff for you guys to you guys a little
bit more of you know some fun in the
chat world war get on that you know and
we're also working on like a community
event thing where you know you you could
play maybe what was thinking about
Friday the 13th
like letting subscribers and you know
viewers plays J Jason and chase all the
lures down so you know keep keeping a
looking for that and once again I want
to appreciate everyone I cannot tell you
how how I wouldn't say I don't even know
work I'm a how many - what happened
today in this in this pocket
absolutely Lord soft mega to have you
back in the from always wicked to find
people find you and I see you put the
stuff up for dizzy as yeah guys again
yeah just to reiterate with attic said
thank you so much man every week we see
the growth every week we seen you new
faces in the chat people you know people
talking about the podcast and bringing
new faces to the to the fold so we
appreciate that so much in fact you guys
stay here and listen to our foolishness
this this is what it's about right well
thank you thank you very much for that
and again as I said last week and the
guy said the week before Lord he needs
our help look this is a difficult time
right now in terms of fighting cancer
and that's off brother so once again I
put it in the chat um please is ego go
let's go from you it's $5 $10 whatever
you can do to have about our brother so
you know also the newly married Lord
exactly - lady dizzy Lady Rose
resolution yo - you know
ride at night that is the definite
walking the plank that is the definition
of a ride and our relationship in
Essaouira the pictures show the royal
wedding was fantastic but sorry continue
so no I forgot about that absolutely
yeah that's a beautiful thing so please
support any way you can no doubt Lord
kid with all the smoke demand talking oh
I can't keep up with your kids going
over first thing we can do is you see
Skeletor back there happy Halloween if
you haven't seen the video you can get
to see me as a clown let you know how
much I'm truly I know we can joke we can
have fun and I hope we brought some
light to your day because you guys
brought light to our day by going into
that super chat and it's not even about
that super chat it's about 300 plus
people stood here to engage in my
foolishness and thank you so much for
sharing with us too for being with us
today also I like to give a giant shout
out to graph
god there's no only day that we had one
acquisition we had another acquisition
graphic God is fantastic in all work and
stuff that he does like I said the Lord
filled Dominus Maximus Spencer Shay in
the teespring store as we speak um I'm
like everybody else I'm speechless
because this just started out as a
couple of dudes in a house fax playing
games and you know we was laughs that
was ridiculed we was told that we were
lying that we weren't even playing games
or whatever we were doing whatever but I
I do have to say that to have that bond
that friendship to grow into something
else to include you guys thanks that
means so much to me thanks that's why
I'm here that's why you know I do this
that's why I show you the statutes and
somebody probably thought I was bragging
no I just want y'all to see my love
because y'all give that love back to me
so I'm just trying to show that love
back to you guys
tremendous show again salute to the
check like Alec said just wow like
humbling um we we definitely appreciate
the lovely field of love we're gonna try
to continue to give you guys quality
content and big things planning for the
future that shows all that loads of
gaming dotnet is on the rise we got a
lot of stuff cooking you know the Lord
is gonna be at these events so please
check that out the audio and all that
good stuff bye my man Lloyd Qaeda box
who will be going up later and of course
tomorrow stream team somebody stream
team members was in here we saw
old-school-style l-boogie you know I'm
saying PD and MJ the boss tomorrow they
will have roundtable with the stream
team I don't know a special guest yet on
PD so you like to tell the people that
which twit
I don't know cuz you always you moving
out here beauties moving man they they
want to be on the show so it's good to
see the growth they're just again if you
want something of why people get into
the YouTube game why they get into
streaming this is a perfect show for
someone getting started to give you tips
to give you inspiration as to what
people have done to get their careers
going and we really appreciate what PD
does for the room but yeah man that's
all I got that you guys were sticking
with the audio and all that stuff add it
gotta go to sleep King is about to yell
at
everyone please good work okay so I've
gotta go to work
everybody please enjoy your Sunday the
Lord's out